foreign
[Applause]
do you want to maybe take a second to
put your microphone in your mouth or
do you wanna do you wanna just do you
want a sec do I look a sec do I look
like I need one
what are you saying just take a sec I'm
in no rush by the way you're this close
to telling me to relax well uh and calm
down you entered eight times and I I was
just like I think she could use some
sunshine I think you could use a
microphone near your mouth oh here we're
going then okay yeah we are we've been
going we're okay we're in I got you
those flowers that is that's that's to
say thanks I haven't seen you forever
okay
can I tell you something about flowers
yes it's easily the only gift I
personally appreciate oh well that's
good like thank you so much yeah as
someone whose mom did just die
and I'm fine it's it's good like she
it's it's finally not sad I I'll go I'll
take them back I get them now are you a
little I got the bigger one yeah yeah
wait I didn't even think
wait this wasn't for my mom died right
because that's just disrespectful sorry
about that I'm joking no no I'm just
saying I think that a lot of at first I
thought people were sending me flowers
and I was like I just watched someone
slowly die why are you sending me things
that slowly die and then I was like no I
like it okay I like it I love it and I
just want to say thank you because I
think a lot of people go like should I
give someone flowers or am I giving them
a chore This Is My love language okay
thank you okay well I'm glad it uh
happened so thank you to your wife for
whoever got these uh me me did you go
into like rock and roll Ralph and get
them out of the fridge no I was I I uh
yeah there's a Ralph's down the street
yeah but I was like this is this was the
nicest thing they had there I was like
all right let me like truly thank you
yeah and I was walking I was pacing in
and out while uh Steve was uh hanging
out here waiting and I came in because I
was just looking at them I was like I
was like oh no this is my favorite
flower it's called thistle I would I
would it literally looks like a weed to
me this is well most of them are purple
thistle see that how beautiful that is
oh so I was engaged and uh didn't uh
didn't pan out
anything can we talk about the Holocaust
can we just we're gonna get to that
let's talk about abortion right half
Jewish you did Ashkenazi does that make
sense we've known that we've all known
that for a long time
[Laughter]
oh the way you operate in this town of
come on you got it it's a second
language if I was Jewish the weather
would be a little better
I'd hear about a lot more
I I would have thought I was a Nazi
Germany whatever you want what do you
think I'm doing in these Tomatoes upload
the whistle pitching ideas okay Steve
bird is here can I give context on you
are you sure first of all the first
thing I asked most guests that people
are kind of like they're like is are we
friends
I believe we're friends yeah I I will
tell you this and I was a little peeved
but I you know I would
uh during pandemic when it first
happened there were like literally just
a handful of people that I miss seeing
in the hallway I miss seeing at the
store I miss seeing like just in general
and so the stores was the place you
would go I found out that we
only enjoyed a lot of people there and I
was like oh I missed this individual so
I I reached out to a handful like two or
three times and by the by the second or
third if they don't get back it's like
all right well just I'll see them when I
see them right yeah and you were an
individual I reached out to but I I I
also know like how was it but wasn't I
on um according to everyone on uh drugs
and cocaine like remember during the
pandemic did I not well um
no but I also know it's like it's one of
those things where the minute you see
somebody you just catch up and you never
know what somebody else is going through
that's true and the text is kind of like
if they don't respond like what are the
chances I saw and went nah look I've
been there like Comics No I know we're
just like shit I'm I'm about to fly
literally and then you forget it
pandemic is so you're making me realize
the pandemic was a bunch of like spoiled
brat like for Comics we're so used to
seeing each other at night yes like
because our job is our hang and then we
get to catch up and then the pandemic
happened and we're all like how do we
hang out how do I see my friend and we
were like let's do a zoom comedy show
it's like let's just do a zoom yeah
catch up it's humorous like we don't
know how to just be normal friends yeah
and I think that that that's a judgment
I don't mean to be a judgment but I
think we're all like like hearting each
other's tweets like we just like didn't
know how to hang out right how do you be
a human without the identity of being a
comic solely the driving force here
every day is a comic and then it's taken
away from you it's like well not just a
person how do I when a comic just texts
you to check in you're like they're
gonna uh what what podcast do you want
me to be on the podcast what is it yeah
you never do your product just say it
yeah I didn't want you I didn't have a
podcast I'm joking I just mean like but
my my answer to you is I absolutely
um
do believe we're friends from my
perspective you are somebody I've always
appreciated and respected and anytime I
met a young comic when I lived here in
LA and they'd be like what do I need to
do what I'm like I'm like literally
you watch somebody like Whitney Cummings
especially back in the day when you when
you you're always had a backpack on
you're always you're constantly like
working you just work and I think
wearing a JanSport backpack FYI great
way to get male Comics to not flirt with
you that is true one is a man repelling
device and a wide New Balance shoe that
you used to wear I think it's a wide New
Balance and the JanSport okay are we
friends I am I'm missing a chromosome
and a doctor a doctor gave me those
sneakers by the way by the way you
should show me the prescription but it's
like I have to wear this by the way this
is this is how where's your mask where's
your vax card and I need to see the
prescription for this I have a real one
and a fake one which one for the
snowshoes please no okay so this is how
demonic
my work ethic was and I think it might
have been a like type of OCD or
something too I don't know all of those
diagnoses are wild but I started wearing
velcro New Balance shoes because I
thought like oh
tying your shoes every day takes like 15
seconds times seven days a week we're
not friends it was nice seeing you bye
guys thank you you know where to find me
we're swimming I'll be the guy in the
Ford Fiesta out front blowing his brains
out
uh what Whitney and then I was like
because there was also this clip of this
football player I don't remember which
one like maybe art monk or some shit I
don't know but it wasn't him and like
every everybody that lives in a gated
community in West Palm Beach over the
age of 80 is wearing Sketcher velcros
and then but I was like I think this
saves me time but what I did all of the
things I was doing to try and like be a
professional comic right even though it
looked crazy at the time
it did make sure no man ever tried to
fuck me yeah guys like what guys like oh
Whitney let's fucking do it he's like
you want a roll bitch hold on
take off the one no keep the shoes on
baby they're all pedophiles
I dressed like a kid from stranger
things for about 12 years okay season
one and two yeah by the way not one
comic by the way I've never hooked up
with a comic you know that yep why did
you look down when you did that you
linked I did I don't fucking Judge Judy
me you're like you're like I read the
Tells no I'm telling you I I've never
ever heard of you being with a comic
yeah but there was some uh she fucked
someone to get this right which is so
funny because it's like I think she just
worked hard but and I'm gonna tell the
story about how we met in a second
so i i s I think I wanted to work really
really hard too not only because I I
knew all the comics I respected I knew
how much work they put in
and um and I knew I was like oh you get
good as a comic if you work really
really hard at like 40. like that was my
thing it wasn't like I need to go to
sitcom it which was ironic that I kind
of did in a way but I also think I was
playing defense on people saying she
fucked her way to the top so everyone
could say like she works her ass like no
one was I you know what I mean like I
didn't hang no I I think you I was
scared if I were to be blunt I I think
you're you're somebody who and I was
talking to a comic the other day about
this where
um you you were the first comic I ever
heard the term brand about you were
discussing what an agent had talked to
you about branding with you and talking
about
prior to I think comedy was just like
you could just do stand-up yeah that's
it you're a comedian that's it you were
the first comic I saw that was a lot
more business savvy but you can't just
be a comic these days you got to be
spinning a few plates to keep relevant
well because you were the first to do it
and it's corny to say like what what's
my brand but I think it's a helpful
exercise to
um uh what's the word when you um
compartmentalize focus like Focus Comics
hone your focus because we can do so
many things sure we can make jokes about
airplanes or this and I think when I
started as a comic I was like what's
funny to other people okay Comics do
airplane jokes what's my airplane joke
that no one else is told
um uh which by the way is all right I
can't you know that sorry I'm in a place
where if I want to time out and go on a
tangent I'm going to okay because here
for it every man that makes billions of
dollars on podcast does it so I'm gonna
do it too oh okay one of my favorite
things Steve has ever said or done
frankly I think about it every time I'm
in the airport is your joke about the
way to get people to stop talking to you
about blades when they sit down is when
they go like
I'm gonna butcher it oh um being like
hey uh we're we're headed and you just
go thanks
[Laughter]
thank you so much and then I pulled my
hat down and that that's that's the joke
and you haven't and it's true and they
just go fuck either they go thank God uh
yeah we he thank you no we don't have to
do this thank you for stopping me from
doing that that's weird I'm so sorry I'm
that person now all all these oh sorry
God please because I think before you
take off people are anxious like they're
like do I need to check in with this guy
do I make sure they're not a murderer
whatever or like does he want me to say
hi or just like I want to get in good
with this guy because we have five hours
together sure yeah I don't want to be
like I want things to be awkward
uncomfortable yeah but also just I like
that when two people just go like how
you doing thanks we're done and we're
both like yeah and then also if someone
does does want to talk to you it's like
an energy vampire and it's not their
fault they didn't bring a Blog they
didn't they don't have a fucking hobby
they don't have Fruit Ninja on their
phone like why the fuck am I your source
of entertainment yeah I mean like but
then you think the odds you go there's
fucking 80 seats on here and I hit the
fucking lottery I gotta sit next to
fucking town banana today and hear this
shit there's only one time I I I'll tell
you all these years I've flown one
conversation I've had on an airplane it
was with Nestor Campbell who is an actor
who I don't I don't know at all but
woman no I he he was the mayor of Gotham
City in the dark he's he's working all
the time he was in Lost and a phenomenal
actor and one of those uh character
actors it's in everything you see them
all time and he was flying to Vancouver
and he let me guess Lassie to coach no
no no no no no no no we I love when you
meet someone in every movie and everyone
thinks they're like billionaires and
they don't know they get paid like a day
right rate of 500 but they're in every
Marvel movie yes yeah it was the one
time where I was actually in like in in
first this years ago and I was like I
was like oh I'm at first and I'm sitting
next to an establish act with how much
we travel it's kind of easy to fly first
I'm not brag I'm just saying when you'll
get the upgrade even if you don't buy it
when we say we fly first
it's like we're the latest assholes like
we don't
you're
just for a fucking what we just went to
New York for Anna delve remember the
ticket was like three thousand dollars
yeah for like first class or something
you flew in the you flew in the mesh bag
right that she carried and stuffed under
the seat the puppy dog makeup on there
we go good girl I did for a while
this is so crazy when I was like doing
you know you do 80 cities a year not
trying to get points for it that's what
we do for a living I did order off lime
when I got really obsessed with emfs
like a sleeping bag that was like EMF
proof but I would sleep in it on the
plane
yeah on the inside like the guy from
better call Saul's dad right her brother
that just wears like heels it does help
like a snuggie here's what you don't
here's here's the only problem with your
joke
okay this is 15 years ago
you have to behave in a way that they
don't even think about it oh yeah yeah
yeah that's your problem yeah because
you're here America's dad over here
nice guy yeah people look at me on a
plane and they're like she needs like
space like we can't like she is
she is honestly like put the kids in the
back like she's like a pro like you have
to come off a little dangerous or mine
is mine is this we have garden hose and
running car look you're like oh you
vitamins I've got a vitamin I'm like I'm
fucking I sit down and I get to work I'm
pluck doing when's the last time you
just never
D batteries you have some of my favorite
uh jokes when when is the last time you
got to uh
relax and and like just did I just tell
you he was gonna tell me to relax but I
called it no but did you just steal my
thing
sorry you were saying no please no I'm
just honored to be sitting in the same
seat as Dan Levy was in so the best hair
in comedy by the way and Dan Levy and ah
no the best here in comedy is actually
his one-year-old daughter penny
um uh best hair and comedy that's a good
game ran is easy oh thick thick hair by
the way fishy it's a little fishy yeah I
don't know about this even when he comes
out of the shower it's still like but
like you can take a shower again
but he takes it no more he's the only
person a lot of men do this they get out
they wash their hair they get out of the
shower and then they put in like Pomade
it's like no that's what you that's what
you wash out
you're washing it out yeah yeah but then
you got to put it back in so it looks
normal do you
does anyone think it looks cool Pomade
yeah I don't know what you told me
seeing a guy with Pomade have been like
sick uh you've never seen a Ryan
Reynolds movie apparently I I saw one it
was called uh
uh lash Lampoon's Van Wilder I was in
college I interviewed him in his Four
Seasons hotel suite because I was a
correspondent for my
College television entertainment uh
station and that is also a movie based
on Bert Kreischer yes
and by the way I I dare you to ask me
another question you won't I I won't
yeah I make it so bad that you won't do
it again I'm punished I I understand I
smoked all the cigarettes in the in the
closet Daddy I won't smoke anymore
um I did Bert's podcast Tuesday and I'm
still hungover I'm still like I I I'm
not what are you drinking these days
because because by the way I also let me
be clear I would like to work on this
new thing uh I'll just do it for me and
if people want to fall asleep fine but
I'm a rich white woman so if you don't
do what I say I'll like you'll
so like I will be
sorry I get I'm so excited to see you I
think that when I haven't seen Comics
that I love for a while we should
probably hang like the night before and
get all of our get it all out of here
sillies out yeah and then podcasts
because I just like have so much to say
to you that I cannot say on camera it's
wild but okay but uh but wait oh yes I
think now when we say someone's a
scumbag and Hollywood or comedy we we
can't say that unless we give props to
someone who's not
so we spent a lot of skills people not
people I'd saying Kevin Spacey's a
fucking creep you know Bill Cosby's a
rapist but you know who's not
Jim Gaffigan sure exactly that's a great
one exactly yeah by the way it's not
that I couldn't think of one I was just
trying to think of a friend yeah that uh
would be willing to be looped into this
fucking entanglement
Anderson you know who's not Tom Papa
yeah you know who's not Steve Byrne
right like let's lift uh other men up
that aren't
[Music]
we just don't
we there's no news article that's like
Steve Byrne loves his wife like no one
wants to read that no no my wife doesn't
want to hear it no yes
I almost feel like guys like so you are
rapist
but you know who's not my dad
so can I first just say uh the um uh the
the risk of possibly being quite boring
uh how I met Steve you probably wouldn't
remember this I tell the story a lot
when your name comes up okay which is
when I first started doing comedy
um I booked a stand-up spot on last call
with Carson Daly okay like six months in
it was probably a little soon for me
this was a time where female Comics like
a lot of people comments like I'm not
getting what I deserve because I'm sorry
to mock I don't even do that
so like I don't know what voice the
female comic complain you know we
whatever our job communities are
professional complainers so always take
everything we say with a grain of salt
like we'll complain
about I mean Gary Goldman one of my
favorites we'll complain about sugar
cookies for 45 minutes
as if it like it is true if your her his
daughter was killed by a falling sugar
like that's how much will
something benign look you know something
kind of lovely frankly will get under
our skin yes you know in nowhere in the
joke is it like and it gives you
diabetes it's like that's not even my
problem with it you know what I mean
it's just like mince meat
like that's just a fucking two-hour
meltdown like little shit right I feel
like we're like emotionally dyslexic
like we don't give a f like Wars and
stuff we're like we can't do anything
about that because I can't do something
about these fucking things why why 18
minutes on that why why Ukraine I will
never know anything there might be a war
we'll never know we'll never know but
what I can so we focus on what we can
control I think yes yeah so at the time
I was like okay that this is a long way
of saying I think that oh I have a
really hard time answering when people
say was it harder for you because you're
a female comic and like
being a comic is impossible for every
gender for everybody I actually think in
the beginning but at that time period I
would agree with you
at that time when you started say
something though yeah I do believe I got
a couple opportunities before I deserve
them because they need to check a box I
should have been doing stand up on live
television after six months
the jokes were good they were good
enough for you to Myspace me but let me
oh sorry good
if I'm gonna tell a complimentary story
about you you all of a sudden go ahead
no no no no no I'm kidding I was just
listening yeah I just love you but I
agree with you yes at the time but I
think yeah I don't know I I maybe I
deserved it I probably did to do there's
a Booker that's booking it that is
Bookers they don't I don't believe
Booker's book something to to check a
box especially back then I think that
they're seeing something or they want to
be the first to go oh her TV debut is
going to be on this show oh
so let me ruin her carrier by putting
her on before she's ready I'm seeing
stock before anybody else is buying in
not interested in this and then it
becomes like uh people buy stock because
I did it even if they weren't going yeah
it is an interesting game of but the
validation was that it was it was there
so yeah I did reach out on MySpace
because back then too like you're a
young comic you do watch the late night
talk shows at that time period and you'd
always be like oh who's this who's that
even if we're following each other on
MySpace because we're both comics and I
posted it like you weren't like I'm
gonna watch Carson Dale who's this young
Talent who the fuck said this Comics we
know what every other Like Comics are
doing it's like our we have to know yeah
I mean that's how Bobby Lee and I got
friends because I saw his set on Tonight
Show and I wrote him on MySpace too and
when I came out to LA like a few weeks
later
um I asked if I could meet him and
that's how we initially met and I was so
complimentary but I was I was literally
like I was so enamored with stand-up at
the time and I would watch all the late
night NFL's comic was on I was like oh
this is fucking great who is this person
you know this is the great Comics aren't
like who the fuck is this guy like great
Comics enjoy watching comedy we like it
there's a lot of comics these days that
don't like comedy so when comedians are
trying to like I don't even say well
comedians that word is just so it's even
insulting to annoying woke people at
this point like I don't even think it
means anything but like even the sort of
this like a little bit of a new
generation of comics I don't feel like
we ever did it like you're way ahead of
me but I don't think that that that your
generation of of like the killers and
then there's maybe one between us and
then maybe like we never tried to like
Dethrone our elders we were never like
that guy's got whereas a lot of the
young people that are like you're
problematic you can't fucking say that
you're like what the fuck are you doing
why are you by the way you don't have to
like us but you you're
I'm here for a reason coming for you're
next if you're trying to come for Comics
sure the next generation is gonna come
for you because you just set a standard
of perfectionism right yes and we don't
do that in common and presentism
what's that like like literally judging
everything from the present to that I
did not know that that's
something 10 years ago that I don't
think is yeah okay first of all you're a
comic we don't find anything funny
yeah no shit
like honestly for you to think I'm funny
I would have to throw myself down a
flight of stairs and just like
um so then so I guess for me I guess
just like I'm kind of like
I I'm a little bit cornered sometimes by
this Narrative of like oh male Comics
are creeps you know what I mean and I'm
like
I'm so sorry that's just not my
experience as a female comic yeah like
um that I've ever been on the receiving
end of
um I've said what I've said on Twitter
but like you know I then get a DM from
you and and Steve Steven at this point
to me is like a god like you're like a
god to me like I studied you I mean when
we're all starting we've seen people
demigod I don't know yeah you're a God
just take it you know he's like he he
has like this documentary where he did
13 spots a night in New York City like
unheard of but that's a real and then I
because I'm going oh shit do a lot of
spots don't do one spot for three
minutes and then hang out for four hours
like we so because that's the Trap you
get into the comic because I have to
hang out with other comics and that's
when they don't buy tickets like being
friends with Comics is the best thing in
the world but like shit the only way to
get better is being on stage and then so
I'm like I'm obsessed with Steve Burn at
the time this is a fan you know sure
following everything you do
um and Louie and you know just whatever
and then so you DM me and you're and you
know of all people when you sort of it's
impossible to get spots at clubs if
someone does it kind of co-sign you in a
way so he basically he basically DM me I
think I probably still have a screen
grab of it in my uh hard drive thing
um uh you said hey loved your set on
Carson uh Johnny that's all we are and
um
loved your set on on Carson yeah um let
me know when you're gonna be in New York
next and I'll I'll introduce you to
estia the seller yeah and then Bobby Lee
had just done that for me at the store
and I was like oh this was so you had no
credibility at this point so you were
even so then
[Laughter]
so then he uh I write back and I go yeah
I'm actually gonna be in New York in a
couple weeks I wasn't gonna be in New
York right at all I had no money I went
to Buffalo Exchange and I sold Sean
Lennon John Lennon's son friend never
hooked up we were in an acting class
together he left a Duran Duran shirt at
my house that was vintage and probably
his dad's I sold it at Buffalo Exchange
for a couple hundos yeah I did three
focus groups that week fifty dollars a
focus group I think was Neutrogena
Maybelline one other fucking one and
then I was able to get a ticket to New
York and I literally like I was like
I'll be there next week like just a
total lie yeah and then you roll back
yeah
um
cool I said you wrote back
when I say 12
Spot times and Club
uh names it was like state of New York 7
30 at this Tuesday uh and I was like
I literally packed my luggage to be like
fucking this guy
like it's fine
like it's fun like by the way small
price tiny price small price to pay so
I'm like packing have you ever wanted to
sleep with God
so I'm like I'm like packing my like
sneakers with laces you know like I'm a
good shit like my good backpack like my
like you know my like CVS song you know
and like I'm literally like I'm just
ready
um I get there day one I'm doing four
literally four I have four spots in New
York yeah City with on stage with like
Killers murderer it's like due to
Freelander me and this was like 15 18
years ago you know yeah so I get to the
first spot or whatever and I'm like
okay I'm like he's not gonna come
to the spots I'm doing I guess on some
level I kind of thought it was like dude
I don't know but I'm like I'm like why
okay I guess he's like whatever and like
you didn't like go hey where are you
how's it going didn't check whatever and
then I'm at I don't know it's like
danger Fields you got me a couple and
then I think it was comic strip Maybe
you showed up and someone's like Steve
Byrne is here or something and I was
like oh okay
all right
it's a beautiful model I've ever seen oh
yeah oh this was he was just helping me
in comedy he's used to come well I'll
tell you the one of the nicest is what a
nice compliments I ever got was at the
store and this was a few years ago I get
fucked with my self-esteem for a couple
years no no and that by the way he was
kind enough to bring me on tour with him
to open for him on the road nothing I
never hooked up with a I think I might
have hooked up with one female comic
material let's see
I'll let you know
okay that was never like I was like why
would you ever ever put yourself in a
situation especially with somebody you
respect and appreciate their comedy of
knowing you're going to see them again
and working with them because we're all
going to go through this pair the
process of a marathon and the only safe
place we have are these clubs why would
you make it toxic and distracting also
uh I guess I just think it's important
to tell that story because I did that
like I did it right like it was a
Rorschach test and a lot of times we go
into situations with people that are not
doing something malicious and we project
because we've been like I'm the one that
went okay guys I'm fucking this guy like
you didn't do that right right you just
you just did what US con what Mafia
Comics do which is like I know that this
is I was like really like fucking
hilarious thank you and then still to
this day you saw like there's potential
here like yeah like I know that like you
know that you needed someone to help you
sure of course 20 years before that like
someone Colin Quinn or whoever had to be
like this guy like you know and you did
that for me yeah and um then you brought
me on the road with you because the next
way to get good is a comic is to go on
the robo Comics sure you know and to get
that stage time and like I don't know if
I was funny yet it's like unclear yeah
but you were like I'm gonna let I'm
gonna let her work out at the gym
because I you can't get stage time if
you can't get stage shot you can't
unless you're good you can't get stage
time but you can't get good without
stage time and like you knew that like
um what's it called I guess it's called
a pickle like I or a j is it a jam or a
pickle a pickle yeah okay I would say a
pickle yeah so my dogs are uh pretty
much all I
what's the word not all I care about but
um
look the point is if they
pass in the next like two or three years
um
I will be buying a handgun
there's this rigmarole now that like
dogs should be vegan no I shouldn't
worst thing for dogs beans peas and
lentils they thin the lining of the
dog's heart which is why how many
appointments do we have for the dog
cardiologist this week Katie five
one for each ventricle
so I've been feeding my dogs the wrong
dog food for the past five years because
all these companies come out and they're
like what about a uh lentil chili a
lentil carrot everything except what
they're actually designed to eat and now
finally a company is just making food
that does not stink up your garage or
attract rats that is for I haven't even
gone to the copy yet it's called Sundays
okay they sent me this food it has
completely changed my life so this is uh
Sundays it was co-founded by Dr what is
it Dr Tory a practicing veterinarian uh
shocked I haven't dated this doctor uh
Sundays contains 90 Meat 10 vegetables
but none of the ones that screws up your
dog's heart in zero percent synthetic
nutrients besides USDA uh beef and all
natural chicken you'll find digestive
AIDS like pumpkin and ginger that's
awesome plus disease fighting
antioxidants so also excuse me the
packaging is so gorgeous I remember for
a minute I thought it was like the
Scientology prank because I was like oh
they're trying to kill my dogs because
we like I didn't know it was a sponsor
at first and then I was like this looks
too good to be true anything that looks
too good to be true in my experience
usually is but it's now not
all of a sudden this company Sundays
they decided like uh uh unlike many
companies to put the product out
when the product was ready
and I appreciate that you're gonna get
35 off your first order we worked out a
special deal for our dog loving
listeners get 35 off your first order of
Sundays go to Sundays for dogs.com
Whitney and use code Whitney at checkout
that's Sunday's son d-a-y-s for f o r
dogs
d-o-g-s.com forward slash Whitney as I'm
still dyslexic after all these years
doesn't get better gets worse upgrade
your pup to Sundays and feel good about
the food you feed your dog also give
them don't give them that much all of
your dogs are overweight thank you and
then I got the fucking I feel like I
cheated in comedy because I got to watch
you perform every night or every weekend
like Wednesday through Sunday for like
two years well that's very kind of you
to say I'm I'm so vice versa and I will
tell you this probably the the the the
hottest feature if you want by the way
you want if you watched my sets then you
are creepy what are you talking about I
love yours I love I'm joking you're and
I I remember
um by the way I think the hottest
feature act I ever brought out with me
is Colin Jost
that dude's hair I have his books his
book is so good I told him can I sell
your book as my merch it's so fucking
funny I I don't know I I just feel like
the funniest like I feel like there's a
couple like really hilarious people that
no one knows about because they're on
SNL
you know it's a it's it it's a fair
point that you bring up is he in height
like is he in hot like does it air still
are you sure it's still on air I think
it might be a Broadway show
like I just want to know are we clear
there's film in these films probably I
mean like I need to talk to the cue card
guy like there's like I just I I just I
would love to watch his work I just do I
have to go to the show
look you got to go to nbc.com and log in
you got to create an account and then
you've got to watch Saturday to let no
create an account okay he he generally
is one of the funniest guys that's what
I hear ever been around and hung out
with and just naturally funny and on top
of that just the nicest guy I feel like
I'm not
um
cool enough or something like I don't
think I have like the cool kid uh cool
comedy
quotient let me just for example I feel
like I'm just gonna be insecure I feel
like a fucking above ground pool in
Beverly Hills for 15 years in Los
Angeles because we did multicams and it
was like look at those idiots yeah they
can destroy on the road every night
consistently but like they they they did
the most profitable thing you can do in
this fucking joke of a business dumpster
fire and they did multi-game the only
thing that makes anyone any money so
Warner Brothers all these all these they
still only make money off of their
syndicated multicams because multicams
they're the ones that um uh friends uh
Seinfeld the ones with a live studio
audience it's not kids it's not canned
laughter you fucking dorks
get the get just shut up where's my
camera so she's right so we get to make
um
just give me a second yes because I
might want to leave the the let's see
let the teapot simmer and we're gonna
whistle here and you guys can make
community
because we're over here with with three
sets and 20 minutes to shoot yeah here's
what I I think your point is is that
single camera that was clear single cam
you're very clear
single cam is I think we got it
multi-cam is they left we got it hold on
no single cam is doesn't matter if we
got it
because in post we're gonna add music
and tight shots and oh you know what
else even if we didn't got it get it uh
we can actually
redo all the lines we can yeah they can
be we could by the way recast frankly
but in post we can change the angle we
can change the pace uh we cannot change
the amount of money we wasted on all
these stupid locations uh and the number
of people we underpaid and the transpo
people that died because they fell
asleep driving home at two in the
morning and how many punch lines are
Gene looks the camera
[Laughter]
Gene looks Gene is looking at his wife
and a girl walks by and he goes oh she
looks like she's in good shape
and then he looks and the camera and
goes
did I just say that out loud
in comedy writing we call that a clam
or it's inevitably gonna be a reference
that will be outdated by the time it is
I just want to tell you guys as audience
members I am so sorry
that you trusted us with any of your
time I mean frankly reparations for
black people long overdue but for the
audiences that have been watching
self-indulgent trash
let's go what happened I made mostly by
Harvard guys
um and millionaires I'm so sorry that
most shows are made
by men that have like 80 mil cash that
know somebody that did crew
in USC the fake crew that got them in
the USC or that yeah exactly there you
go by the way is that way let's really
make sure you never have to save anyone
via boat
um uh
like was that what kind of was that a
canoe the crew the fucking uh yeah
it's like crew though is like
there you go like it's really long I
have a Hydra I don't know okay ah so
you're the real
the real tragedy of Kent State there's
May 4th and then Steve Burn yeah oh it
was May 4th May 4th 1970 yeah so then we
become like very close friends and if
I'm can I just bring up there was a time
that we were on the road and I saw Steve
after like two shows and like
might have been like a penguins from
Pittsburgh so I'm just trying to shout
out I don't know it wasn't there it was
definitely maybe at a
no no who cares but I'm trying to give
you this paint the picture here because
that's what I I'm I'm ultimately a
painter
okay like I know you think you're a
Storyteller or joke writer I am an
emotional painter yes you know what I
mean where's my
canvas no I mean I paid my I mean I'm
actually construction I'm in
construction
I put my makeup on every morning it's a
lot of caulk it's a lot of grout
I watched you
destroy a game of Dueling Pianos
wait and
a game of Dueling Piano you know what
the the what like comedy clubs like
here's the thing you don't understand
about us we are the comics we are the
most oh in Dallas Texas how about this
you know I know what you're talking
about you know how there's Downton Abbey
there's upstairs I've never seen it but
there's upstairs
uh upstairsmen
upstairs Abby upstairs Abby downstairs
and downstairs Abby
we are in downstairs Abby's like the
help we're the chuds no no what's that
cannibalistic human underground dwellers
but we actually so
so you know how the underground is like
the lowest Street respected people yeah
we're the ones in the down downstairs
down Abby that go hey you guys know
what's crazy and and they ignore us yes
yeah like we are the law the scum of we
are the lowest of the law on the wrong
you know and sometimes when we do our uh
craft like people hit us like they throw
stuff at uh like it's wild and yes we
we're like people like uh the Vegas
you're playing Vegas like we're in the
kitchen most of the time yeah we're not
like with Tiger Woods like we're like
like just slipped and fell and like the
oily ass floor and kitchen like we're in
while we're dipping a mozzarella stick
yeah but is it mozzarella that's cute I
don't know that's cute looks like dumb
to me
you know what I mean like we are
treated like garbage like like but we
love you know so it's like after shows
we the cool part though is we get to
party with the quote-unquote staff yes
the waitresses and the fucking people
that work at Dueling Piano like they'll
stay open for us they're just like fuck
around yes because we don't think we're
better than them right right yeah
because we're not well that was maybe
Adam was that Addison Improv Addison
okay nice nice so I just remember you on
a piano and being like I really want to
hang out with Steve but like Comics the
way we have fun is like you wouldn't get
it
like even when he's having his down time
after performing two shows he has to go
perform on a piano like we're never
we're never done more me yeah
the waitress is like we just watch both
your shows why are we watch we watch
this guy can we can we suck your dick
so we could have a good story or
blackmail you one day and get the money
we deserve it it's just like why okay
but it's also funny because we go
I'm great at comedy yeah
I'm not that good at piano but I'm gonna
make you watch that like it's like
Michael Jordan playing baseball be like
come watch me play baseball we're like
well we're watching you practice the
hobby do you do it all my chocolates
here
what Steve does it ever end Steve is
like hey bitches come back to my hotel
room and you're like so sourdough so
it's a seed and we're like can we get
let me go back and get something more
comfortable and I come back with an
apron at a chef's hat so who's hungry
okay so because gluten allergies yeah
the flower from Italy doesn't and we're
just like can we fucking do blow off
each other what have the comics being
fucking cool what happened to Comics
being like cool and dying half the time
yeah we're back now we're kind of back
now we're back no now we're back
do you um uh want to talk to me about
your respect how many can I is it if you
had nine specials five this is five five
yeah this one took five years to to get
right because I pitched it to everybody
and everybody said no everybody because
because when you sorry not his fault
everyone else is because when you pitch
something to someone who's not a
comedian someone who's say yes a lawyer
at best who now runs in like everybody
like that's right like everybody you
just said like everybody said no no
um everybody like we're just trying to
get to you guys yes we're just there's
all these
um Epstein Island fuckers in our in
between in between
us and you we're just trying to get to
you yes this man has been touring the
country for 15 years like people paid us
they just want to see you but then we
have to convince someone that only wants
to hire for diversity to hire someone
that's Asian and I but it's just like
what else do we need like do I have to
show you my ticket sale like what is it
gonna take yeah for you to know that I
might know more about comedy than you
yes Taylor
who just graduated by the way Taylor
yeah uh Geffen like your dad runs AEG
yeah how did you what like you know
I think it's there I think that like the
comment with except I think Robbie pro
at Netflix like I think that comedy um
Executives they kind of get off on being
a little sadistic with us because
they're not they're honestly a common
executive like if I make you laugh then
I'm probably not make you know what I
mean sure yeah I'm not for you but
you're making shows for masses because
we're we we want everyone to think we're
funny right not like your friends like
in Los Feliz that have trust funds like
they're never gonna think I'm funny
because we talk from the point of view
of the ever like I don't say every man
because I don't see gender
um you know what I mean so they're just
sort of like oh look at look at this
girl talking about her relationship and
all this relatable stuff like I'm Paulie
and you're like okay well most of
America kind of just wants to laugh yes
not be lectured to by
um uh not to go here's a comedy special
psych it's a TED Talk you're racist like
that's right
and I think that's what happened with
look that's the
the whole Genesis of this was the late
night talk show is dying okay so it's
called the last late night because it's
like variety shows are are they're dead
and the last so you went to a bunch of
networks that have late night talk shows
and went hey so
your jobs are gonna be gone pretty soon
uh so I just want to put some Nails in
your coffin yeah uh none of you are is
it you should all maybe go to Santa Fe
and start making soap sooner rather than
later go to chat GPT so that's and find
a new profession yeah I literally just
had this fucking dork that I'm dating
tell me about that oh that's because he
told you okay Pat you winked again
that's two
one two Steve and I are dating now
though 12 strikes and you're out 12 is a
lot this I know that's my favorite thing
about spread them out long enough my
everything will go fine this is my
favorite thing about how fucking
brainwashed I am when I talk about like
sexual predators in Hollywood I'm like I
did work with sexual predator and he
came into my trailer and pushed me up
against the wall and I got away and then
he asked me on a date and then he uh uh
you know uh I went I just felt like I
had to complain and then he you know was
inappropriate with me and then he tried
to get me really drunk one night and two
years later I blocked that motherfucker
yeah wait how why didn't how why did it
take me so long to block to like like to
be like this guy fucking hit me across
the face he told me I was a dumb whore
and three years later I was out of there
[Laughter]
I put up with that for like three years
too long yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean it's just like a funny thing where
it's like it doesn't even occur to me to
have self-respect like I forget that
it's an option or I used to forget but I
I like it I mean I don't think it's
funny you know because it's hilarious
you're not oh so you don't think women
are funny no no no no here we go okay
here we go
[Laughter]
hey okay
by the way by the way we're at the point
where we really could be having Strokes
so maybe don't that's true that's not so
I did I did uh an hour special where I'm
doing a talk show a talk show is
basically three Styles writing
it's Quant quick one-liners monologue
it's panel storytelling it's 20 minutes
of stand up and it's making me five
years to figure out how to do it because
people think oh you're a comedian just
go roast them just go crowd work it's
like no those are all muscles you got to
work on so
um
is uh stealing
from your life
crowd work wait like crowd work in a
special it's like they're not they can't
see the person right right yeah yeah
it's cheating crowd work is like it's
it's there's Geniuses at it you know
obviously Rick Ingram's a genius at it
you know mag's a genius at it but like
Rogue Comics like you doing crowd we're
gonna special it's like we know that's
like I'm not saying it's the easiest
thing I'm just saying for you it's
fucking I mean I've seen it it's not
yeah that's why so in this one the
commercial breaks I did crowd work for
one minute oh nice that's it so I did
transition I'm not just doing crowd work
yeah that's right yeah so so it again it
just did that because it's smart because
they're showing people this looks a
little scripted because of the the
fucking um their similitude of like how
fake this has always looked but don't
get it twisted motherfuckers like I can
do all of this on the fly yeah you
basically just went I can do anything
try me like try me right except maybe
like you know cry at a funeral but I can
do anything besides that I can do
anything besides hug my dad oh my God
and look him in the eyes but sometimes
when we hug we just side hug now it's
getting better I could do anything but
cry at a funeral I will remember that
line when I'm coming up on my deathbed
and things are flashing and I don't
laugh the whole time that's the one
thing I go
I will be at your funeral laugh
I'm realizing this because I think that
I've been so I've been told by so many
people are joked that like I'm crazy or
I've kind of internalized that of like I
guess I'm crazy I guess I'm psycho I
guess I'm this but I think the comics
are main
um not Maine but uh things that are
really easy for other people most people
are really hard for us and things that
are really hard for other people yes
come kind of naturally to us yes so I we
can like uh manage I mean you've seen
everyone here has seen uh Comics getting
physically assaulted on stage and have
handled it like fucking
literally that girl had a uh Ariel she
had a no she's like surely she had a
beer can thrown right in her head and
she just went anyway so Trump like
everyone's talking about the person that
threw the beer can but not the girl's
reaction that yeah of course because
it's it's almost like it happens every
night or something yeah it's almost like
people try to attack us a lot I mean she
didn't skip a beat didn't skip a beat
and most people would say she's like you
know I don't know how long she's been
doing stand-up that was even not even
doing stand-up that long right you know
what I mean so I think stand-ups
I think we've become stand-ups in a way
we were doing it before we were doing it
with a microphone on the stage whether
you were defending yourself at dinner
with your family or defending yourself
at school or trying to get attention
some way or trying to get a girl to like
you or whatever yeah you know or that's
just the way we see the world
dude I love
I love a bat shit wedding speech oh oh
yeah I live for it I've like the ones
that sort of start out bless you
especially guys at weddings yeah when
they think that they're complimenting
the the bride bride by going
all right so I've known Steve for 20 or
24 30.
and
look I'm as surprised as you guys are
then he's settling we never thought we'd
see the day
because he's a pig and everyone's like
what like I mean
Elizabeth comes along and she's like not
even his type
and we're like huh remember the Russian
she was so beautiful
but you're nice like you have like
you're 22
yeah we didn't think she'd want to go
with an older woman like it's just and
then you're like dude fucking no no no
no yeah no please stop friends from
college should be able to make speeches
at the wedding unless they have taken a
sobriety test
and a psychiatrist her like has approved
the speech yes period that's not a bad
thing to think that the the bride should
approve the speech that is not a bad or
not I don't know who's paying for this
thing who pays for all these fucking
things I was engaged and I was like who
I'm who's paying aim for all this oh me
got it
is that where it was driving towards why
the fuck would I want to have a wedding
yeah I'm like in the fucking black red I
don't know so I'm gonna pay fucking 200
grand for a part like I get attention
all the time I don't need this
like I don't every day like what do you
mean I'm gonna go put on a dress like
well that's that's always the the
Romantic the Romantic guys like we did
it at City Hall it's like no you cheap
fuck you didn't save up for this you
piece of shit it's her day by the way
it takes way more effort to park at City
Hall than it does to plan a wedding and
you know that
so
more stress and it's more you know what
I'm really big right now not on what's
financially expensive what's can you
imagine being a tuxedo and a wedding
dress and you're driving downtown Los
Angeles you're like you can't go right
on six I'm trying to go on fucking fish
let's just go home if you didn't take
Olympics you're getting a divorce anyway
the fact that you took the L.A freeway
system on your big day means you're not
gonna make it anyway because you're
you're dumb and you ubered here and
she's gotta here off yeah okay now my
score they're just like we don't know
like I'm not even I don't even want to
rate these fucking motherfuckers like
it's just like
I don't know about signing anything I'm
down for the party I'm down for a
fucking it's just I sign I've signed so
many bad deals in my life I just don't
know if I can sign another one Geraldo
Geraldo had the fucking best joke I
don't know exactly how he said it one
time and he just went like
um he goes so uh it was something like
every 10 years I go through a breakup or
a divorce or it's like every 10 years
I've I realized that something is a man
is like every 10 years I just have to
give away half my stuff
and the way that he phrased it was just
so like half is a lot yeah and it but I
I just feel like we leave with what we
came with but I guess it's impossible to
prove what because I know how important
emotional support is to someone that is
you know what I mean sure but this day
and age there's so few men that actually
work I think when that does happen it's
like oh I gotta have my shit back
fucking great that'd be nice thank you I
get half of some Samsung that's never
worked no I love you I feel like I'm
flirting with Sam like I feel like I'm
like pulling Samsung's pigtails because
I feel like I'm gonna I feel like I'm on
my way over there because now that
there's a fucking Bill Cosby app on
Apple I'm just I feel like I'm a Samsung
guy now wait what's going on with
Samsung
I uh well Ian Edwards has the funniest
fucking joke ever he goes if you want to
know what it's like to be black in
America get a Samsung
and I think nothing works I think I know
everyone's like a green bubble it's just
racism all over it it's a green bubble
versus blue bubble it's like the new uh
like color yeah racism but I do think I
I'm on your scam Samsung people
they do it because they can't be put on
these fucking chains that go on forever
on Apple your friends they'll create a
chain and it's just fucking useless
mindless meme after mindless time suck
vampire and and you can't add a Samsung
to an Apple chain right yeah like it
just it doesn't get to them like they're
just like
Samsung people are just like miss me
with that shit like I'm good
they're a lot more productive they're
happier I'm good on the like chain yeah
about
[Music]
Tao Rogan's about you whatever the fuck
chain where you guys are trying to solve
politics right like how do I get off
this you know Toby Keith's not hard
right
who's that yeah I'm the Samsung guy now
yeah like oh that's Renee Zellweger's
nope
Nicole Kidman's husband no no Keith
Urban is Nicole kid right is it I don't
know I think Renee Zellweger could be
one of the most talented she I think
what is the term actors I saw that uh
the Judy Garland one unreal oh dude
dunking on hoes for the past 20 years
and people are shitty to her because her
lips are a little chapped
just hydrate a little more she's a Texas
bitch dude fantastic she's a longhorn
yeah they don't there's no water she
doesn't need it not used to it and this
is Californian now there's the water has
survived on Mr Pibb
and okra
this whole like she's not out here
putting on her lip balm so that her so
her lips look look lubed up because they
look like pussies from the side let me
make my lips shiny and looped up so you
can think about fucking them like she's
just like
nah not it yeah yeah she's like yeah my
eyes are a little squinty I'm not
putting on eyeliner can I tell you I saw
the movie ticket to Paradise with George
Clooney and Julie Roberts uh have you
have you seen the film or it's the
recent one the recent one look uh my
wife wanted to watch it I watched it it
does look a little like a fake movie
it's it's enjoyable I get it formula but
you're seeing two people in Hollywood
that you go wow they they're not trying
to cover the potholes with it just like
they look great and that was one thing I
I appreciated about not only the
performances they were fucking they will
say it is very hard to look good when
you have hundreds of millions of dollars
like it's really hard to like you know
what I mean no like so I like they
managed to look good despite
being
I mean he's a like almost billionaire at
this point so I don't know how he looks
so like I don't know what
I guess it's just genetics
so I'm just curious so yes if an actor
if George Clooney
how much did he make on the casamigo
sale of his tequila I saw anyone fucking
buys me I'll lie I think it was the sale
was like a billion but I don't know do
we know how much he got from that
so I would like to know how much every
crew member made on that movie
and how much he made like if he gets
paid to be in movies at all and that
money doesn't just get distributed to
making a more Humane shooting
environment I have a question but hold
on so so I'm a supply chain but a
separate entity 233 million it's that's
a that's the headline so should he be
allowed to make 20 million dollars for a
movie I'm just curious
I think they're separate entities I I
said is it ethically like
well I mean the minute you get into
ethics then when Jeff Bezos comes out a
few months ago and says I want to give
all my money to charity
your fucking warehouses but also not
even so any charity by the way you guys
sorry I don't want to say he's a
criminal
I'll say it a different way which is I
don't think he knows what he's doing I
think that these fucking dorks that
didn't get laid in high school like
they're addicted to success and they
don't they they they and I'm not saying
this is they were bullied fine we all
were I think they kind of like
like have this hyper Focus that's really
useful in society but there's not for
lack of a better word like an emotional
babysitter going oh hey all this success
is pointless if you see human beings as
numbers or um
um what's the word like assembly line
robots sure so I think we have a lot of
robots that are
bosses of humans and they are just like
they can't relate so they just don't
think about it like well I'm giving him
a job and I'm giving them health
insurance like they don't they just they
don't they're not boots on the ground
with their supply chain because he's
mostly like building yachts
uh with his you know hot ass girlfriend
like he's just like not thinking there's
his brain I think truly I think we go
jet base is a criminal like maybe but
also everyone stop ordering from Amazon
why are you using the service first of
all I only use Etsy for everything even
my tampons which is why I am always
smell like Worf but
foreign
I've been around many Korean a kitchen
and that's still disgusted me
North Korea
every night is Fear Factor at my mom's
house and that made me sick okay sorry
good
[Laughter]
so I'm a little more concerned with the
person under Jeff Bezos who's getting
paid millions of dollars and their job
is actually to he has no fucking idea
what's going on it's your job to brief
him it's your job to show him like it's
like but you're talking about
redistribution of wealth her so so my my
thing when you bring up George Clooney
right I mean there's a two totally
separate I would just feel weird if I
had 230 million dollars taking a check
for
um hanging out with uh my friend and
being like wee and then everyone else is
getting paid I don't know how much
everyone's getting paid on the movie I
just don't know but maybe he's creating
a lot of jobs because you know I'm just
like this whole thing there's I just
feel like there might need to be unless
it's uh I just think there might be a
limit to like how many millions of
dollars someone should be able to make
because I think it becomes like a sick
addiction or they don't even like know
then you're bringing I think unless it
um is me in which case but if you're
bringing like I I would think the
federal government would have to come in
and hard cap based off of metrics like
what is George Clooney's value what is
his value internationally domestically
et cetera et cetera I think sorry real
quick yeah sorry I think no I'm sorry
because I wanna I don't want to uh yes I
don't think because then we're just all
paying the federal government government
more taxes to make sure he's so I don't
think the fact I think it's on I think
it's on us to be the leaders I think
it's on him to go I mean he does I'm
sure he's going to run for off as soon
as my guest just guess he has it in his
family but like I don't think we
consider how to go well the government's
gonna come save us the government's
because he's never gonna happen sure so
I think we go you just have to police
yourself I don't think the average
consumer is going to sit there and watch
ticket to paradise and go through the
metrics and understand he made that sale
off of the shit but I do right right and
I and his wife is one of the uh huge
mandatorian correct uh
uh human rights lawyer well right so
this whole thing that like guys don't
know or women don't know Ellen didn't
know like sure if you don't know that's
it's your job to know right if you're in
charge so when there's uh the kids
mining Cobalt in fucking uh Congo see
I'm everyone's gonna win he's crazy so
No One's Gonna Hear this but
you know whatever listen to the smart
people to talk about it Siddharth
something he was just on Rogan and he
went down to the mines and he saw women
pregnant women with children on their
back sure Cole about mining which is
what how the batteries hold right in our
phones and they're getting paid two
dollars a day and the fumes are so
incredibly toxic like and then it's like
well I mean like all the companies that
may like must know about this well I
mean even like the California Water yeah
they know and not care or do they not
know because no one everyone's too
afraid to tell them like you I I think
literally if we're going through the
Grievances of humanity and
redistribution etc etc of all the things
going on you'll you'll literally put
yourself in a depressive State and put a
shotgun in your mouth I I went down a
rabbit hole on where all the water is
going in California is it is it solely
um is it solely just global warming is
it drying up whatever but 80 is going to
Agriculture and like Palm the wonderful
company like pistachios one pistachio is
a gallon of water so by the way but that
is your that is it pistachios almonds
take a trip and we're like almond milk
or they're going to China
a majority of them a majority of the of
the nuts that we that we produce here in
California are going over to Asia
surprising I'm surprised they haven't
figured out a way to grow them and
like green inner Greenhouse sure type
things but I I think like the minute you
go down that it's like well well then
who's going to come down on on a company
like wonderful because that'll never
work I think it's this I think we go no
one's gonna come down on them because
they're all investors in these companies
and they benefit it's the unfortunately
and yet again the onus is on us to just
stop buying it and what we do as Comics
is we can't con fix it the problem we
can't change the problem sure we can
we're the hyper feelers that read an
article and like we don't just go school
shooting we just go like
if we feel it and we it hurts us and we
carry it with us and this is like our
we're we're Martyrs I'm not saying that
I'm like we're the hyper feelers who go
like
this doesn't add up don't have the
solution just just putting it out don't
shoot the messenger we're really funny
and you're gonna listen to us and we're
actually gonna sort of go this is kind
of shady right anyway
let's stop by and then this and then we
have platforms like this and we just
like stop buying from Amazon like if you
need it because your baby is bleeding I
mean don't wait come again
hold it if you're baby hold on if your
baby is bleeding if you could just send
them I will handle it personally
um I will speak with my uh
um I don't have a facialist but um like
it's on us to stop giving them our money
and I'm not saying don't buy it don't
look at movies pirate movies no
um like we just have to stop using
Amazon
and it we have to drain it from the
inside and just start buying from I
think for now for me it's Etsy because
there's black owned women-owned native
owned mom owned where you get all the
same stuff you might not get it tomorrow
but anything you get in 24 hours
someone's getting hurt
there's no Humane eyeliner by the way
most likely it's the person that's
shipping it to you I've seen them they
come to my gate and look they have back
braces on yeah did you get it and I'm
like yeah you can just leave it there
like I need to take a picture of you
with that and I'm like what yeah like
because if a package gets stolen they
get fucked and I'm like doing a water
like like they're just like they you're
like what the fuck is I just saw Jeff
Bezos on he's they're rebuilding the
Netherlands so his yacht can get through
with like he's building his own damn
yeah like he's fucking chilling dude
that motherfucker he's like doing
ayahuasca
like in the Maldives
yeah by the way first class yeah
yeah the Jeff Bezos of wives
you know what I'm saying so he's having
his rum Springer because he built his
whole business but he's not paying
attention so who the fuck is running
this company like who I want a name I
want a name who's the Jeff Bezos has no
fucking clue what's going on right he
thinks that people are in his factories
or his Warehouse is going whistle while
you were sure but like she thinks it's
like the greatest job ever I know a lot
of people that work for Amazon including
my dude downstairs which is like in
warehouses like they do give health
insurance like they do uh a friend of
mine that works in Amazon warehouse in
Phoenix had a kid so they let him change
his hours to night shift so the baby
doesn't bleed uh I mean look yeah
and then I'm sorry and then uh the wife
could you know care for it during the
day and then they just had nocturnal
hours but it's like should that is that
like the best we can do like I think in
his mind or whoever's mine that runs
this is like oh yeah we give them health
insurance but like they don't have time
to go to the doctor with that health
insurance
throwing lip liner to a millionaire
yeah that's that's that's
and it's only going to get worse it's
only and it has gotten worse sorry no
please as two people who would love for
our specials to be streaming on Amazon
bite my lips like she's gonna ask me
where it is it's like it's on Amazon
okay so happy to cut it no no no no no
no no keep it all in because I mean look
because then they're not supporting it
it's up to me to fucking they're not
doing anything they're not listening
Amazon delivery guy go watch it
I gotta paint take a picture
I just shit in the bowl
scrambling so it's also just it's just
like I just want you guys to know like
how embarrassed like it's always been
comedians have always I think from my
experience not gotten respect like
Rodney Dangerfield 101 but it's like we
get respect from each other and it's not
like disrespect it's just that we're
seeing as clowns and that's fine that's
what we want because that's how we get
to say things like this because we're
all so funny about it so it's like if
you guys think we're dumb or silly or
like sure that's exactly what we want
you know fine but um
you know it used to be that we had to
grovel to Comedy Central right right I
the year that I got an hour special
after I did the roast I
did not get live at Gotham 140 Comics
got it it was like a show of like show
hundreds oh yeah like can you even name
60 off the like I'll wait I'll I will
okay 140 yeah and then I did the Joan
Rivers roast and then they you know
wanted to do a big deal to me and then
it was here's uh here's an hour like
hour yeah they said half hour and I said
I'll only do if it's an hour yeah
because I just like a weird delusional
confidence because I was like there's no
way if I do a half hour I'm never gonna
be able to get an hour right like I just
like and I had an hour that was like
ready now but leverage but also half an
hour back then was like what five
minutes like it's like our specials used
to be 42 minutes sure with commercials
so now it's like Netflix specials like
60 Minutes you're like no one and then
they're like well it's hard to get
people to finish them and you're like
yeah well no one's ever watched 60
Minutes Or home of like she's kind of
new you know yeah and then which is why
it's so weird when Comics like I'm only
cutting up my shit online it's like it's
gonna be Central used to cut up our
specials oh yeah yeah and you were
literally like and then when my mom died
and then it's like you know smash you
Taco Bell exactly and you're like well
yeah like what's up like somebody or
like Jesus man so it's like there was no
flow to the set sure
and so we used to have to gobble to
those people and then we had to gobbled
to like see so and by the time and and
then they disappeared and then we had to
gobble to quibby and it's gone it's just
like and now it's Netflix we grovel yeah
it's what we do and then people say no
and we go please and we go no and then
we go I'll pay for it myself and I'll be
out of pocket as long as you just air it
please and we're happy to do it sure but
then it's like Amazon comes along and
it's like
am I groveling to like a grocery store
yeah
on Amazon I don't know how to do it you
could get you just had one on Netflix
yeah that's I still believe that that
right now is the platform and and if you
if you watch specials otherwise they
don't suggest it in your algorithm if
you're not suggested in those first
three rows and if you can't catch like
the way people choose specials now sure
it's just like Dahmer
well this thing wasn't unoriginal this
one wasn't original and so when you
don't when you're not an original you
don't have the real estate it's not even
on the home page you know the first
thing they say Robbie Pratt I love you
so much the first thing they tell you
those it won't be on your home page
that doesn't even make sense is it well
it doesn't make sense but if I if I but
if don't watch
if your own special isn't on your home
page that means you're a comic that
doesn't watch stand-up specials right so
it's a little bit like mine will be on
my home page but I actually watch other
comic specials and I think a lot of
comics don't want to support other
Comics they like don't watch they're
special or I've just seen you fucking do
this for a year I've seen it yeah but I
also like seeing the aesthetic I like
seeing the production value I like
seeing what went into it I like to see
who worked on it I like to see the final
execution of it and even I was talking
to my wife about this not to bring up my
special but but that's why you're here
but when I when I was doing it I told my
wife for five years I've been doing a
set in comedy clubs that was never meant
to be in a comedy club it was meant to
only be performed once and it was at the
taping and nice and then I think most
people do
sets on their special for theaters that
were meant to be shot in comedy clubs
yes most people do I agree we'll do the
opposite weirdly I think yeah it's it it
I don't I think they're so
it's almost like we're in the fireworks
business it's like that's correct magic
magic what next it's magic and it just
doesn't have the sustainment correct but
I think the key is really just finding
your fucking people whether and it's
like for me I don't think about getting
new fans anymore I just wanna I just
wanna uh make the fans I have proud that
they bet on me
right like I just want to fulfill the
promise that you guys weren't dumb right
like I'm like you know new people like
do the work but yeah but it's like but I
work for them they invested in me sure
they gave me 80 bucks every
whatever two years that I was in their
town and like the people that go I saw
you last year I saw you two years at
like those are the only people that have
the people that have it's so weird
because I think it's Comics were always
like the people that had paid to see us
were like okay got you okay so not you
how do I get you right like and it's
like dude why am I even thinking about
you like these are the if I just stay
loyal to the people that fuck with me
because then otherwise I'm gonna change
and I've seen this with Comics I'm gonna
go okay how do I get this guy I gotta
get I gotta get barcel Sports people so
now I'm just gonna be like this bitch
that's like does this and then the
people that follow me is like who's that
person right yeah like that you know
what I mean so I'm just like I don't
know I think that that with Comics like
it's so hard to control who likes us and
why because it usually it someone has
nothing to do with us so like
I just try to be good and if if things
go well fine but
if they don't it's it's always like
yeah it's it's interesting I I almost
quit a few years ago like just when I
was like I I think most of I think most
of the best Comics do and by that I
assume you may I mean commit suicide
uh you're probably not far off by the
way but you guys like I'm not kidding
like look at the batting average like
they say that right now in entertainment
black rappers is the most dangerous job
yeah in comedy I mean it's like people
are physically harming us when we were
doing comedy right after the pandemic
the vibe was so fucking tense sure I had
fights in pretty much every show I have
the video of the one of the fight in
Dallas it was after the show 10 minutes
a guy just pummeling people we are the
make magic sure but no one felt safe
inside so we were just fucking like
managing Terror we also manage people's
Terror right and like it's really
exhausting and then people go like nah
I'll watch a special and I saw him but
like
you're like are there any loyal hoes
yeah yeah I think we have to get back to
um the only thing that people really
watched when it's on is what sports
right because it's live it's an
imperative to watch you know yeah I
think Chris he's talking communal Chris
you there's impact we just go like here
it is and we we go here oh the audience
member get to it whenever you want but
no like right there's no we're and
they're never gonna get to it they're
gonna go like EV like people that I
truly believe
like love me right as an Entertainer for
whatever reason
um the dad dropped the ball whatever it
is
um they'll be like I
I I'm I have not seen your scholarship
I'm dying I like and I'm like I know
yeah it's been six months
you might get to it yeah you might not
sure but why would you rush so I think
it might be going back to like Latin
because remember when when television
started doing live shows NBC started
doing live Undateable was live quiz and
live musicals because the numbers start
going up yeah you know because I think
we've we've spoiled audiences so much
going like you can watch it whenever you
want and then when you do go to find it
I'm gonna go watch Steve's burn special
oh my God I can't wait to see Steve oh
my God he was he was in town a couple
months ago it was the funniest shit I've
ever seen I want to go see a special
wait Ozark I haven't seen Ozark yet fuck
yeah oh God yeah you know what I mean oh
God the Pepsi documentary okay no no I
need to see Steve special oh my God ah
Richardson like they're showing other
shows yeah that go I know you came here
to see a comic but what about this and
you're like yeah so it's like audiences
like there's no place that's just for
comedy anymore we're competing with
fucking
Bridge or ten yeah do you want to see a
48 year old Asian Elon Musk or Chris
Hemsworth shredded with his shirt off
swimming because he might be dying it's
like yeah I want to see Thor yeah it's
like you turn it on I'm like I'm gonna
go say and then Sandra Bullock's just
blindfolded on a boat
I mean you
you really wanted to see my friend Steve
oh my God
you know what I mean ah my buddies are
here Clooney and Julie are back together
got it I can't I gotta ever since though
she's 13 they branded me you know what
they have been so good to me get the
gang back together again they really
have shown up for me yeah and the least
I can do is show up for them because if
they're movie bombs I mean he might get
he might be boxed off as poison and we
can't have that for another six months
because he don't we got that
did you look in the mirror and go well
you got your looks look that jawline
don't chisel itself
that's right
okay
yes
are you sitting down
yeah
but mentally
yeah I know you're physically shitty now
right are you like are you sitting down
okay now I am yeah okay
upside is an app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out
see yeah
you may not know this about me but I
actually love mountain biking I don't do
it often because sometimes it hurts my
crevices so I'm working on getting a new
seat so it can get expensive though to
do this hobby especially with all these
price hikes lately you know the wheels
and the the air squirter guys and the
kickstands I mean the kickstand the
kicks big kickstand
this is why I have got to tell you about
my new favorite way to save money that
you never should have freaking had to
spend in the first place it's called
upside upside is incredible app for
anyone who buys gas groceries or dines
out with upside I get cash back on every
purchase that I use to fund my mountain
biking addiction slash crevice
abusing machine it's basically cash back
for just doing you it's what we all
deserve okay download the free upside
app use promo code Whitney to get an
extra 25 cents back for every gallon on
your first tank of gas that's an extra
25 cents back for every gallon on your
first tank of gas using promo code
Whitney okay let's go let's let's bike
up this mountain together
can I um just before we I know I'm
giving you way too long I'm being
selfish as fuck um can we Circle back to
uh literally
literally okay yes is that it wait what
what do you say what what happened I
think Whitney hears a CH in there oh
literally is it literally or literally I
don't know the answer I would say
literally yes you did and my brain if
I've been saying it wrong this whole
time literally litter you tell me
literally I was told not to say it at
all because if you're saying that's a
thing it's literally like I got in
trouble when I wrote my book because I
say literally literally like I was like
I was literally 15 years old it's like
yeah no we know right you're like yes
you're 15 or you're not you know what I
mean I mean right yeah they'll say I
mean right look I'm literally confused
about how to pronounce literally now
that I I don't know if anyone knows I
don't know me either and I've I'm I'm
48. I've used it a lot no but I would
say that the older we are sometimes the
less we know because we've been
practicing the wrong thing 100 no I
think it's
what do you say because I also someone
the other day I was talking to them and
they were like
in uh interesting and I was like
how do you say it interesting
interesting interest interesting they
went interesting and I was like I would
say interesting
now you tell me and you this is like
when you have food in your teeth good
friends are like food in your teeth but
if I just say to someone hey interesting
and you're like like I say Aunt I get a
lot of shit for that that is what is
that though my Aunt Jane my aunt that's
a son and Aunt is more fancy who gives
your shit for that what kind of my
father is very
um he I I think the Irish in particular
have a real relationship with the
English language and my father's always
been keen on pronunciation on wordage
verbiage definition
very very
etymology is my obsession so it's like
when someone says like what did I get
the other day there was something I
can't remember
um fuck of course I can't remember now
the same people that I'll call you all
fucking cunt yeah are like hey you're
saying that wrong I'm sorry it's it's
it's literally it's like well you're
asleep in a gutter so why are you
yelling about my grandma whatever I'm
doing is working yeah try it
um also can I throw something out really
quick sure I feel like did just in terms
of thinking about you saying you know
I've wanted to quit a lot you know even
when things are going ostensibly well
I'm like
you just heard me on that phone call I
was like I don't want to be I don't want
this I don't want to be a part of this I
don't like where this is going I know
where this is going and this looks like
a big win everyone wants me to do this
but I'm telling you there's no way under
these circumstances
I'm not going to be humiliated
right right you know what I'm saying so
that's really when I want to quit when I
go I've earned the right
to be in charge of this thing and people
are still
about questioning my instincts sure sure
and I'm in this Byzantine entanglement
of bullshit
like but the option is going to be up
soon so we have to move and I'm like I
didn't do that right like you guys did
Bad Business and now I'm like I'm the
one that's gonna have to pull off 15 000
Miracles sure you know what I'm saying
and yeah and like that's really when I
want to quit because I go oh things are
going well and I'm scared and miserable
you know like that and then when things
are going like not that well I'm like I
know but I know okay this this we can
only go up right this we can only you
know what I mean whereas I'm like we're
at the top and like I mean you know I
don't I don't know exactly your
experience on your when you did your
multi-cam I mean you did it for three
years which is like by the way my
favorite thing is when you've done a
sitcom for let's say one year two year
three years and people that have never
had one on tell you like oh your show
was canceled and they joke about it and
you're just like okay
um all right so we don't care but it's
just like you'll we'll never we have to
find the validation within our job is to
find validate is to um earn validation
from other people but we can't do it
when we're not on stage like we're the
we're we yeah we needed them my main
work I feel like in this has been on
stage I love me let me let me let me let
me let me love it because you're paying
me to do that and it's my job
to fucking cow cow
if I bomb it's always my fault it's
never the audience's fault my job is 100
my job is to make every audience laugh
and fucking figure it out that's right
so you're paying me for I'm not gonna
take my toys and go home because my
first joke didn't go over well right I'm
gonna go all right let's fucking go dude
agreed you know what I mean 100 is on me
like this these are people's they've got
babysitters right whatever yep and so um
when things are going like well in like
with the in like the Hollywood space
which everyone sort of thinks is the
goal I'm kind of like
this is spooky this is gonna hurt this
is setting me up to be embarrassed and
setting me up to destroy my personal
life and my physical health and like
sure everyone's gonna call me crazy I
know it because I'm gonna have
boundaries and I don't like the way and
there she's difficult and then I'm like
I feel like I'm
you're a professional is what you are
I'm just not gonna let that shit slide
and we're not hiring that way and
there's got to be Child Care on set or I
don't even want well let's and then
usually people go no let's just get the
deal done and then we can sort that out
later I'm like no no no the parameters
are what you earned you earned the right
to establish the parameters on your
higher hire the guy that you think's
gonna because like
by the way here's my deal with the movie
business at this point I'm like I
haven't seen a really good movie in like
eight like I don't think you guys are
doing a good job of making good movies
currently I think there's a lot of great
uh TV but like I don't think you guys
know
what people want to watch but again it's
it's Gatekeepers it's the industry and
it's always I I you know my wife uh you
know I could cry thinking about it she's
been so supportive and there was a
moment in time a few years ago where I
said I'm the best version of myself
and I can't get anything going right and
can I but we don't the grades don't make
it to like
make it sure like this is like it's I
feel like I think about this all the
time because I go like oh the ones that
are next I mean this is where exactly
where Bill Burr was 10 years ago yes
where everyone's like who's this you
know like the the the person killing the
hardest they uh people always figure it
out like 10 years later right like this
is where like it's a girl like all it's
like sure you know and and I do think
there was a little there's a little bit
of a punishment
in a way and I don't say that as like a
little bit of a
what's the word like of a um
Dang or something on the people that
like we were getting Hollywood
approval-ish kind of like 10 years ago
while the people that weren't were
starting podcasts
and we were going like oh well that's
Plan B you know like if I do that then
they're gonna think I'm just like doing
a podcast in my basement but I'm
supposed to be doing these like TV shows
without and then
it's not that we didn't have the
foresight it's just that like how do you
say no to that right right so much of my
the last few years you know between
Sullivan's son a documentary the opening
act
um all those things were okay you
accomplish these things that stand out
on a resume like I couldn't get on a
late night talk show to promote any of
this stuff second Asian American sitcom
on television after Margaret Cho three
seasons not one late night talk show all
these things and so that was the impetus
well my own talk show then but it's wild
because the metrics you guys is not that
all Asians the same fine obviously it
doesn't matter but you guys your number
one market is
Asia it's one of those things where you
got to sit down and you got to look
yourself in the mirror and go is what I
was doing good enough
and so I took a lot of accountability
and I said the next thing I do I've got
to fucking do twice as much work or
three times as much work and so that's
why this goddamn thing took so long
because because you know when the people
sorry the ones that started fucking
scoring hard and I was like Louis CK's
show Louie is genius yeah because he
kept saying it's not ready yeah it's not
ready yet it took three years in between
right and something that you and I both
did is that how do you learn without
getting the experience and how do you
get the experience if you don't learn
and you and I both learned in public you
and I both learned how to run television
shows star and television write
television shows while it was airing do
it we didn't have any prep there was no
we didn't go to film school we didn't go
to TV school like none of that's just I
mean is that just a money laundering
scheme or a um it has to be Eugenics
program at this point I don't even know
um but uh you know we we're like unions
are telling us oh you can't hire this
person you're like well I want to hire
yeah I can this black guy is my friend
from The Comedy Store and they're like
oh we already have a black guy and
you're like oh you know what I mean okay
um so we were learning in public and
when you guys saw us performing on our
TV shows
we were in a disassociative panic State
and it's still great oh yeah yeah I mean
I remember one day they gave me eight
pages we did the first table we did the
first run through it just to run through
a three then we did the actual taping
eight new pages and the first time I saw
them is when they go action so I'm doing
my lines and I'm behind the bar with
every fucking scene and I'm still like
memorizing for the next scene
that was the most panic-stricken I've
ever been in my entire life and I've
driven my wife to the hospital as a
baby's cup like that's like oh that's
there's a surprise there's a primal
understanding of how to get your wife to
the hospital there's nothing else to
think about right I know this goal
when you're on a TV you have no idea
what the goal is is the goal to get the
producers still the executives will like
me more so they'll pick me up am I
trying to make people want to fuck me am
I trying to make people am I a leader
like there's no adult yeah in the room
you're the adult in the room though no
one thinks we can be adults so so just
there's also been this myth we've
comedians have been Gaslight and
gaslighted uh to flub on this sentence
Pat is real back no no no no gas lit gas
lit yeah because I'm about to say gas
lit into thinking that we like can't run
businesses and I've like
you know I mean flubbed on that of all
comedians or comedian two ends comics
so people have gone like you sit at the
kids table right you're a comic yeah and
we've got the adults here the writers
sure who are going to actually Wrangle
you they they know what's funny yeah you
just go on the like you go on the road
and perform for like hundreds of
thousands of people and make them laugh
for an hour straight but like you honey
oh honey yeah okay
none of these writers or showers oh
that's cute none of them have seen any
of your specials and it's not personal
it's just they don't want to be here
[Laughter]
um so they had shows that they uh that
were pilots that didn't get made so they
just kind of like need a job in between
when they get to have theirs and frankly
like they're kind of like annoyed that
yours got picked up yeah you already
hear some stories about Legacy actors
that maybe your parents know that you
don't get ready to hear a lot about that
how about by the way how about this how
about halfway not that there's anything
wrong with this I just like I feel like
it's I'm in you just saw when you came
in me being an asshole because I was on
a call for an hour no trying to get
questions answered for a project that I
think I'm doing that I'm like hold on
hold on can I just get some information
it's like it's like someone it's like an
arranged marriage like can I get to know
the team yeah can I get to know like the
people involved it's just like boom
you're gonna work together for two years
in a box and then in a dark room in the
edit right like what's your last name
like can I just get a like you meet me
at Chili's for like ten like we just
yeah also whatever we'll talk about the
office another time
um but uh I guess it's just like there's
everyone's in such a rush because that's
what the the TV you guys made this
stupid system up this pilot season and
we had a shooter and we gotta air it on
Fridays like like the I always say the
multicam TV business it was like the
schedule was made by like for men that
wanted to cheat on their wives and it's
fine it's none of my business but it's
like why are we shooting the show at 5pm
a.m on Friday like right no like
oh oh you know what I bet none of these
people have kids like there's just no
way it's like when someone brings like a
cat on a plane you're like
what are the chances that no one on this
plane has a cat allergy right yeah but
none of us can eat peanuts yeah like the
fact that you thought
is someone that would love to bring
animals on planes
and can't because I'm like and if
there's one animal you could leave in a
home for like eight days by itself it's
a fucking cat by the way bringing it how
about this bringing a cat on a plane
abuse active abuse it's being radiated
like all fuck yeah it's miserable it
doesn't want to be there no one wants it
there how about this let me do it better
cats shouldn't be domesticated
they want to be outside yeah open the
door see what they do
they're gonna by the way you've never
seen a cat smile until it's outside by
the way go to a cat person's house and
you like open those
yeah
and then
nine Gates and cages to keep the cat and
then they're like have built a whole
like it's like Shawshank for kitties
they built like a carpet Forest yeah to
keep it intro like it's in jail hair
floating yeah why do you need to keep
this thing in the in your home so bad
and it it doesn't even like you no
nothing like anyone yeah they don't sit
on your lap they don't come over to you
look I love my dogs but as my friend
Maddie pointed out she's like I was like
dogs are just I would love to get cats
at some point but like dogs like they're
just so loyal and she goes my dog will
jump in any car if the person opens the
door that is fucking hilarious
you're kind of like that's true
like no questions asked it's like a
three-year-old kid it's like you're my
friend right like we're cool but if a
better opportunity comes along it's like
a woman dating in her 20s so I have this
theory that women dating their 20s I'll
speak for myself and not all women
because they're all so different
um they are but you know this you know
what I'm doing
my God you guys love generalizations
admit it um is that I think that when
women date in their 20s like I was
working on this as a joke I I don't know
if I ever worked I was too scared to do
it was like
men will cheat down and women will cheat
up so like like women are like I'm madly
in love with you right
um if you're a real estate agent but
like if a doctor comes along like I will
upgrade whereas God a man will be
married to like the CEO of a company but
like if like a cute babysitter comes
along well downgrade yeah yeah
at a very large cost but no questions
like men are always looking to downgrade
and women are always looking to upgrade
well I think that's why you never see
like a group of guys there's like groups
of girls always backstage at the concert
right or the but
Lady Gaga like there's no like swath of
dudes and football jerseys being like oh
she looked better last year
I love you gay men but like they are
like at this point they're like I don't
know about that I'm like how did you get
meaner than the straight men when did
that happen
straight men are telling me I look
pretty prettier without makeup I always
you're telling me to take it up a notch
I had a joke that never worked but it
just it gave me it was funny gay men
will will will take the nicest word in
the language and make it mean Hello so
it's like anytime hello it's like oh
Jesus
why are we in a fight
maybe maybe you couldn't maybe no one
wanted to marry you that was my thing
with a lot of my gay friends I was like
we're fighting hard to fucking get you
get you fucking marriage rights you
deserve it yeah
but why are you married yet it's been
five years
maybe it's you no better audience member
I think than a a nice Core group of gay
guys the best yeah they got all that
money if you're if you're gonna break
down like General like worse gay guys
blacks Latinos uh and then whites and
Asians are tied for like uh
I'm still a little Rowdy nope uh I dude
Ontario is my favorite I'm there this
weekend it's like oh I'm so jealous ding
ding ding here we go to cancel my Oxnard
shows because I did an announcement and
um I just it didn't hit
wait what happened I did like hold on
hold on when you say it didn't hit that
was so subtle but it's like uh oh drum
roll let me get a forking knife where's
my bib what happened so I like am doing
this big like I wanna I kind of I love
doing theaters I love doing clubs more
than anything that's where you get good
like that's like the gym I also love
going back to the clubs that I did uh
that first of all headlined me before I
could sell tickets right like I will
always go back there and then in between
theater tours I love doing just the
California
improvs that I've always done Oxnard
Breya Irvine uh fucking Oxnard is now
called Levity Live though sorry yeah um
whatever sometimes uh you know San Diego
La Jolla like just to get good for
that's what we do and so I'm here with
Pat were you here when we shot that yeah
fucking hell you should see what I cut
out of that let's show it let's show it
can we do you know what it is I can I
just want to show it because I want you
guys to see hold on so wait you got in
trouble for this were they
um I do have to go on the local news and
speak with the mayor what do you have it
can you can we play it here yeah I'll
pull it up when did this happen
a couple weeks ago I was going to Oxnard
one of my favorite by the way I'm
looking at you know that like we got to
start buying Oxnard like people went up
dude yeah like Malibu billionaires are
buying an Oxnard now really yeah it's
fucked up
and there's the second apology no I'm
saying it's fucked up yeah the people of
Oxnard should be oh hopefully they own
because it's about to be like it's about
to blow up it's about to become the real
estate's about to come so expensive that
kind of the people that I now know kind
of live there it might be prohibitively
but again you could go down this Rabbit
Hole California where one million units
short and so they're saying by 2035
they're gonna uh just housing units
that's why the homeless homelessness Etc
et cetera and that's why you know they
said we need to end cemeteries
and just go green right is that the new
thing just build apartment buildings on
cemeteries uh because I don't think our
ancestors would have wanted us to be
paying higher prices because they were
in a
and then Alum house is going to come at
you for all the new pitches that they're
getting because of this idea here we go
so okay so let me know if this can be
pulled up yeah because it is important
that a a real touring comic sees this
also okay so I'm
I know people think that I like grew up
on like a English Estate with horses or
something right yeah you know like
whatever but hold on not yet not yet can
I give a context yeah I'm gonna get the
audio going here okay not yet
you know it's my biggest pet peeve when
a video starts before and you're like
well now it's now you've seen it
now it's over
um
so
Santa Barbara is like the wealthiest
area there's La Jolla in California but
like sure Santa Barbara Oprah lives
there Montecito right it's I'm not sure
why there must be some
it's beautiful isn't I I I do you know
it's by the way it's like what do you
think is the most beautiful real estate
in the state of California
the Topanga Westfield Mall
I love it there I think it's I do I
think it's a I think it's a feat I think
it's I think it's a beautiful I think
it's a beautiful you know what I I
think I mean we also need to note that
clearly
you you were exhausted on this day
this was one of the days I feel like I
have my shit together in this video this
was one of the days where you were the
most tired I think you had been up for
like two days traveling we did like are
you talking into the microwave like can
they hear a microphone right here okay
cool
[Music]
you were returning from a trip this was
around the time where uh we did the New
York trip oh Jesus you were slammed for
like eight days the fact that I don't
remember shooting it tells you
everything you need to know and then we
and then we were asked to turn this in
that day so then I'm fine let's shoot it
so great so I'm like fine let's shoot it
because I want it to look nice it's
Oxnard I've been going to Oxnard for
sure
10 years and before I do specials I'll
usually go to Oxnard La Jolla in
sometimes Phoenix
and by the way this is me going you guys
got the final say that's how much I like
you guys right right yeah if you think
it's funny I I trust you yeah okay now
because this is funny in certain places
like no I should cut it right you know
whatever certain people whatever so
Oxnard is right next to a place called
Santa Barbara Santa Barbara is the most
expensive place
in California sure right I just think
it's I don't I I'm sure I'll appreciate
it at some point I just I feel like if
you're gonna have an ocean why are the
waves just like
like they don't it's like a kid's wave
pool there's like nothing there where
are the fucking waves man
yeah dude how am I gonna slowly walk
into the ocean
without being sucked in an undertone you
know every good beach needs an undertone
you need a few deaths you need a few
drones just to keep it spicy you know
the beach should be like a will my
fiance come back or not yeah you know
what I mean like some drama but it's
like I just feel like I don't know I
think I'm not like a force old school
Four Seasons sure like it's 400 a night
why haven't they like made the carpet
smell less weird like I just I'm like I
don't I don't think I'm that like a you
don't mind box wine out of a box every
now and then uh but I mean please yeah
as in a pussy
yes please now we're talking so like I
think I just don't do well in fancy
places because I'm like why is this
costume why is it like this is not I'm
not relaxed like like I just am like
want to be in the dirt with my horses
like I'm just not you know sure so an
Oxnard is right next door I hear that my
entertainment lawyer who is could buy
real estate wherever he wants has bought
a
home in Oxnard uh uh okay I have okay
I'm not outing him uh a couple really
big so in my head Oxnard I've gone there
many times sure I think Oxnard is
beautiful right okay Santa Barbara I'm
like feels a little like overpriced and
quiet and like country Clubby and then
Oxnard right on the beach what is the
hotel that is the closest you come in
and you see the fucking Coast it's right
the the
um ocean because I'll take a nap from
four to five wake up and then you see
the sun going down in the ocean I think
Oxnard I think it's beautiful okay okay
oh hold on so book The Tour all the
clubs like sold out I have Oxnard in
like I don't know two months yep and I
get I'm doing a shout out for Oxnard
which promoting shows now it used to be
compost it sold now it's like you go to
a city that you've sold six thousand
tickets in and then the airport
someone's like Steve Martin you're my
favorite what are you doing here and
you're like yeah I don't know if it's
getting to you and you just don't want
to see me or if it never I just don't
think anything we post gets to anyone we
want to see it I I promise you it's okay
by the way you're famous I'm familiar
that's the difference between us so
people always say to me how do you how
do I do I and I answered it one time and
I'll never answer it again it was it was
a flight attendant she goes how do I
know you I was like I have a TV show she
goes no that's not it I go I've done
that tonight show a few times nah I've
had some specials on Comedy Central she
goes fuck no she goes do you work at
Best Buy I was like get the fuck I'm
never ever answering that question ever
again ever you know American Airlines
for the past 82 years
awful so that's the content so that's
the context I'm so excited to go to
Oxnard yeah it's one of the only
California
locations that I could drive back that
night and I choose to stay bring my dogs
spend actually like hang out because
normally Irvine Bray I just drive home
not because it's you're not a beautiful
but it's like I'm on the beach it's
gorgeous sure okay so they're like so
Pat it's like whatever four in the
morning Pat's like you gotta do they're
saying you need to do a shout out to
sell Oxnard tickets yes okay hey
everyone I'm coming to Oxnard on
December 8th 9th and 10th to Levity Live
Now
you're already pushing like I'm already
coming to Oxnard
the fact that I have to like promote it
and tell everyone is so fucking
embarrassing so if we don't sell this
out in the next 24 hours how about this
I'm just canceling
this is already more this is already so
beneath me to even be fucking coming to
wherever the fuck this fucking what is
that place with a wasteland of a
hellhole
so don't how dare why like why am I even
reading this this is sick this is
sickening I'm sick you make me sick
where even is Oxnard
it's in it's like north of Santa Barbara
if I come to Santa Barbara in there or
wherever the fuck this is if I come to
Oxnard and there's not a line seven
fucking miles long down the street I
will set this entire State on fucking
fire
am I I hope I'm being clear
we good yeah good
uh it's fucking hilarious if I if I S if
I want I'd be like that's fucking
hilarious and I I'm kind of jealous I'm
like why didn't I do that when I went to
Toledo well because you'd have to cancel
because gangs were threatening time okay
all the waitresses
um
so then
um uh I think Heather McDonald who's a I
was on Chelsea Lately
um a lot comedian I think she saw it and
got confused like she put it on her
podcast and was like why isn't he being
so mean to Oxnard yeah
um but it's a no I know but I knew when
um I knew something was up when like
four or five Comics texted me separately
being like that Oxnard thing was
hilarious and I was like uh-oh
this can't be good like I knew it I was
like why why is Tim Dylan telling me
my Oxnard shout out was funny like this
is not like Ari shaffir just got dropped
by his agency and he's like hey man
like Nick Youssef like deep cut right
yeah yeah yeah are just like dude
Patrice came out from the fucking grave
and was like good job
so it's like I don't know it's just like
this fucked up stupid thing where it's
like I now know that Oxnard is I don't
know how to say it was like the the the
the
um what do you just call it like there's
a group of people that do all the
service jobs the service of the hotel I
live in Santa Barbara got it so I went
hey service people fuck you
even though
hey service people I'm coming to go
at a show they're probably the the
hardest to laugh at that by the way
I would say at a show they're the
hardest to laugh at that so at
snard Levity Live I'm coming there
the service people for
assholes instead of
sure laugh for an hour yeah and now I
have to
literally the mayor called within like
two hours the mayor called who does
who's my uh my manager
I mean that is so I am so I like am
sorry but like the way you feel about
Oxnard in that which is a joke is the
way I actually feel about the mayor but
also I'm like who the fuck is this
mayor's just like uh like I think the
mayor just wants to get on Morning News
um no that's a joke uh but
would you want to come see a comic
that went Oxnard Levity Live I will be
there in two weeks um please get tickets
um love you guys so much thank you
whitneycomings.com tickets and meet and
greets are gonna be seven thousand
dollars and um I'm gonna be there uh two
days only and never again
what shout out isn't fucking awful yeah
of course it's you guys we're
humiliating ourselves like we're there
used to be people there used to be a
whole departments that would advertise
us they go they did get a stupid photo
of us put it on a billboard and at least
you go on and everyone know like we
didn't do that and then there used to be
people outside of clubs going like want
to come see a comedy show
now we are the person outside the comedy
club going do you want to come see me
I'll be inside me
me inside
or like I'm just basically in front of
Oxnard going I'll be here in two months
like where did the money go of the
marketers right like there used to be a
whole business of people whose job it
was to tell
Oxnard that I'm coming right that
weren't don't let the comic
this is what happened that's right this
is what happens why are you letting me
take over the marketing business but
that's that that's the not to get too
serious but 15 20 years ago maybe even
10 years ago the onus was on the comedy
clubs to get people in the seats and now
it's wholly dependent out of pure
laziness on the comics because oh you
got a following that's why I booked you
oh so I'm going to lose my following by
only posting about Tampa exactly thanks
but also can you not do a story can you
actually uh to isolate it so to take all
the following just do something for a
scintilla of the followers sure I guess
okay who says until just FYI
um uh but also
the way that historically Comedians and
I'm not saying this is what I did on
purpose but the way comedians got asses
and seats for comedy clubs is they went
on local news yes and were fucking
idiots yes at six in the morning
hungover but yeah like we would go on
and make
we would frankly
forget ass back
oh no no but B to be there with the club
yeah we're fucking like you know eating
a beetle at seven a.m like
just like all right I remember one time
I went into like you know I don't know
it was like um like you know Papa and
the worm or something and I oh
like we used to Peddle our we used to do
shows to literally like midnight one in
the morning and then we had to do we had
to get picked up at four a.m yeah okay
by some woman just in zebra print
it was like you don't lose track of it
just get in that fucking Taurus that's
right yeah
straight to you know you know beanie in
the starfish
and it's like you literally walk in
they're like when you come in yeah okay
so we're doing a competition where
everyone is gonna eat a crooked asshole
you in and you're just like guys I just
I just woke up what what uh yeah dude
um you know it's my favorite comedian
Bill Cosby cool like so it's just like
know that when we are not we didn't go
to school to promote like this is not
what we do the way that we always got
asthma seats was to go on local talk
shows and local radio and be so
upsetting that people go I gotta go see
this guy yeah so I to be fair had I come
to Oxnard like I would have done
something probably way worse on the
morning television had you know what I
mean it's like choose your pick your
poison if if comedians are coming to
your city we are gonna make jokes would
you want to come see a comic that isn't
making jokes even about coming to see
you no I I I think every comic you spend
at least the first few minutes kind of
dumping on like yeah one of the reasons
Bill Burr blew up is he was he shit on
the city of Philadelphia when they
weren't driving with him it's like yeah
that's kind of what what this is all
about it's to your point it's like
breaking it all down to the reality
nitty-gritty of like yeah and you guys
the shittiness of the situation don't
want me to be scared of making fun of
Oxnard because if that's the case I'm
gonna be afraid of saying
tranny if it works in a joke I'm gonna
be afraid of saying ma'am or like you
know what a comedian who's afraid yeah
so if you see someone who's afraid
that's a comic like I'm not saying
they're not gonna be funny but it's just
like the chances are maybe a little
lower so if you see a comic doing
something ballsy even it's if it's at
the expense of your beautiful city
there might be a chance that when you
see them yeah you know what I mean sure
because here's the irony if if people
came I think and I made fun of it they
probably would have it would have been
fun there if I had roasted the city like
in an elegant way it was just in a
context that was just like you can't
control but what's the mayor gonna I
don't wanna I could talk off air but but
like does the mayor jurisdiction the
club started getting lots of threats
and I guess apparently a lot of very big
motorcycles were parked outside the club
for like days at a time yeah and so the
weight so it's like I can't put the
waitresses like I I'll always be safe
you know this could be one of my
favorite stories I can't wait to tell
like eight comics about this this is
fucking great
this is really I get it you gotta do it
you gotta kiss the ring I understand but
it's pretty fucking awesome this is my
favorite part of it is when I get the
call we're texting texting and then when
someone calls you're like uh oh
why why are we let's keep texting I'm
good I'm good on the texting and uh
they're like hey so I guess
you kind of
um
tiptoed into the whole like um Bloods
versus Crips Feud by accident and I was
like huh
cool look at all the blue
oh my God I was like which one do they
think I am
oh that's cool so they were like I know
but they were like so when you say Fuck
Oxnard I think it's the LA versus Oxnard
there's a little bit of that so there's
like I kind of fell into like I think
the mayor would probably just want to
help me understand
um how much time I have left on this
Earth and maybe what to maybe you know
what colors to avoid wearing or
something I don't know but there was
just a little bit of a like you walked
into like a
you think I'm cool enough to be in a
fucking gang
I wish
like a a parent-teacher group I would
see like
yeah like a homeowners association
by the way owning a home that's a
fucking scam I just I just realized that
yeah
I I I by the way like I I think that's
one of the funniest promos I've ever
seen I fucking love it Comics get it
it's really not great but I was you just
saw a person at their breaking point I
mean how can you not think that's funny
that's trimmed down like you went on
she went on for four minutes after that
and I didn't even show I didn't show it
back to you I didn't want it to go
anywhere like at the end when you're
like are we clear like I was like good
enough
gotta get out of this one
because that you didn't give me anything
unusual like in their minds usable I was
like well at least she hasn't personally
offended everybody that she's gonna talk
to this week
I just think there's nothing funnier
than having someone on camera when the
moment they snap oh like what like it
was it's so clear that I am just so rode
hard and put away right at this point
and I'm just like why am I the person
who has to do that
isn't there someone who's
is to make sure I sell these by the way
do I have to sell all the tickets why
I'll pay you you know what happens let's
not sell it out this whole thing about a
sellout every venue no no
it's fine yeah the people who figured
out I would like to be there the people
that we have to go you've got I just I
don't want them don't even yeah if you
don't know about it I don't even want to
promote my shows anymore if you know you
know if you know you know and then you
know what I'll pay you the money you
lost on booking me
because it's actually long run less
emotionally expensive for me
that's right yeah because my favorite is
now when you like you sell out clubs you
know you sell out fucking eight eight
shows and they're like uh one at a show
and you're like no
yeah you don't oh you see him he came
really close to that one bonus because
now
they sold out
I'm gonna
they're all they they all got the games
you want to add a show today isn't
tomorrow the first show I don't know
buddy do you want to add a show Sunday
at one it's like why who no one we have
a show Saturday five o'clock show
7 30 show 10 o'clock show
hear me out you added the 530. yes three
shows on a Saturday what about
an 11 15 A.M
matinee show after you've done four
hours of press yeah on shows that are
already sold out
look they just got a waffle maker they
don't know how to use it and we're
thinking this is the perfect opportunity
yes I'd love to help you guys sell
waffles of course yeah I don't want to
sleep in Jimmy and the waffle yeah
do you remember Mancow of course I
remember I
I don't know man I don't know much about
him but the fact that he had me on I
feel like he was like the ticket to
selling tickets in the Chicago area
Midwest right Chicago yeah and the whole
thing was I remember one time I was
touring with Bobby opening for Bobby and
maybe Schomburg or something or Chicago
and probably whatever it was and he it
was like gotta go to Mancow Mankind and
he went to go like do mankind I was like
so you know everyone's like man I got it
oh man if you do me a cow it's over you
sell them you're a billionaire like it
was like our Johnny Carson or something
yeah and so um I'm like finally get
booked on Mancow right and I'm like oh
my God I I'm up at like two you just go
straight from your last show to the
radio station yeah you just like leave
the club at 2 A.M you just go at 4am
yeah I go
I'm like I'm like sitting in the fucking
waiting room still fucking tired and
then there's um there's a band like
eight men with instruments and at that
moment I did say you know what it could
be worse like at least we get to travel
alone yeah without being like can you
just can you hold the okay I'll carry
the tambourine tune it Ricky I don't
even
okay whatever I just don't think we need
to bring the triangle like whatever like
just like fight like there's what are
the chances everyone's on time in the
morning no I mean just like fuck that
I'm surprised more musicians haven't
fucking overdosed on whatever so um
I go in and um you go in and you're just
throwing it he's just like
he's got like nine fucking all over this
place
okay cool and I'm just sitting there
like but he doesn't speak to me for 20
minutes yeah I'm just like like you know
when you like are trying oh yeah like
find your you're there and you're not
even you're Patrick swayzing ghost
you're like by the way they throw you
yeah
but let me get into my
yeah just just let me find my so I'm
like you know what I mean yeah
and then finally something happens and
he's like so like he looks at me kind of
and he's like so like what do you think
of um
you know the fact that uh
what does anyone care about I just don't
know global warming is yeah uh uh yeah
so what do you think about the fact that
Ross Perot is running or something
whatever was happening at the time I
don't know if that was wait that was a
crazy reference I'm sorry I don't know
and then he asked me a question what do
you think about Monica Lewinsky it was
oh my God I was 10. um
like what do you think about Paris
Hilton's nip slip or whatever and I went
oh you know what I think and he went
because he was in an earpiece talking to
someone else oh my God
and I was like wait what he had two ear
pieces in and was
talking to them he had and it was just
like
and you know when you
spend a lot of time talking on either a
podcast or radio thing and then
afterwards you realized it was just
audio
yeah yeah and you're like
why do we why did we what was this yeah
I had an experience with him but I
waited two hours
he never even got to me
Winnie he never even got to me I sat in
the green room for one hour then I sat
in studio for another hour
and I was like so I was just like a fan
like I'm just here and I'll tell you I'm
not a fan like get me out of here
I don't get it I don't think it's funny
I think it's weird I'd rather go on Opie
and Anthony may go home
and by home I mean my my
um my um my give me a pillow to cry in
my captain
honors
it's just like who like what we are the
most dis like dis again
Chris Rock was punched in the face and
television no one stood up just that's
all I'll say and then he gets punched in
the face and everyone's like it's Will
Smith okay
all right so what the fuck I got a
fucking stool to the back I was telling
these guys I stole the back of the head
eight Staples
shit on you
I remember the night you got in the fits
by the comic store oh there was a night
I actually have this written down this
is my favorite thing about Steve Byrne
is she he's actually the most fucking
low-key gangster there is because most
comedians are pussies like when someone
I'm sorry they just are like if I've
seen Comics like fucking like guys you
think are tough and had someone like a
woman in the audience back fuck you and
he's like what remember like I'm scared
you're like Jesus man that was fat easy
there was a night in the or yeah where
you did someone
stormed the stage or throw a chair at
you and then Brett Ernst came on the
stage yeah here's what happened so I was
on stage and as I'm getting up there
um a group of Asians walked out and this
guy is with like three friends but
they're spaced out because there's
nobody there at the store at the time
okay and he's eating wings that's right
I remember there was not a lot of people
in the nobody he's eating wings and he
looks at me goes hey I haven't even
touched my kid he goes your friends left
and he goes
I go what he goes your friends left and
he's eating wings and he's licking his
fingers I go did you say that because
I'm Asian and so the people are Asian he
goes yeah I go well if they're outside
maybe I should go meet them he goes
maybe you should I go well maybe you
should fucking meet me too out there he
goes maybe I will let me tell you
something
he wasn't joking like you're joking
right now yeah yeah like this
motherfucker there
that is just like
and then we're all kind of in the
hallway like because with the comics
that you don't intervene unless
it comes to what it came to it feels
like physical name because I had a
comedian a man come on stage when I was
performing dealing with a Heckler oh and
come out on stage behind me and go
and I was like no it got really weird
and I turned around I was like
it was wild and then I at Chicago
LOL Festival when it was there for like
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then afterwards
I got off stage I was like shaking
Sebastian saw it and he was like get in
the car get in the car and I was like
shaking and I was like I don't like it
was like 12 o'clock it was like some
dirty show at midnight like it's just
unnecessary like crazy and um
uh I called the next day 12 comics
all and I said what would it what would
it take for you to go on stage right if
another comedian was dealing with a
problem in the audience sure 11 of them
said there would have to be someone
physically charging the stage and I
think damarella said I would have to see
a gun like that's how like you let him
handle it yeah yeah until it's physical
dangerous so we're all sitting in the
back like
like yeah you know what I mean
yeah whoopsies and then I remember Brett
Ernst well I got the guy and I I we came
together and I just started wailing on
him and he's on the ground I'm wailing
on him but his friend I didn't see his
friend picked up one of The Comedy Store
tables and bread Ernst tackled the guy
otherwise I'd be eating out of a straw
right now I mean that's what that's the
reality those tables are fucking Turtles
excuse me you're not allowed to do
straws anymore
everyone that eats out of a straw like
you are killing Turtles even if you're
like don't have a incapacitated too yup
yeah I got it that's what the whole
point was parents were both
incapacitated I don't let them use
straws yep
the yeah I don't want to kill the paper
when you guys out there that do have a
chance of living
that was wild dude but I'll tell you
that was one of those incidents where
your young guy and you don't and Tommy
was like hey
oh yeah all of it but it was like no I'm
a moron I'm a fucking idiot as as much
as you could go I beat the shit it's
like no you're a fucking moron your job
is to fucking handle the room under any
and all circumstances period across the
board be a professional the minute I got
up the stage I was just like any of them
if I'm me say something if I may yeah
agree
and um your therapist nailed it with
this whole thing and you exactly right
but at the time at the time like it felt
great at a time where racism like it
it's like it kind of it's there's a
point where like just enough is kind of
enough and sometimes we have to bite
back there's a there's a time there's
yeah because I'm sure there have been I
mean maybe it's like I'm trying to
relate but like there are times I'll let
that one slide I'll let that one slide
and then one day it's just you did this
you just did this on the wrong day
that's all yes yes I left the Laugh
Factory early to get here and I I didn't
go on the date with the girl that I'm
into because I told her I couldn't
resched and then I got here and then
there's comics in the back and you kind
of just like disrespected me there's not
really a lot of people here so you just
you're embarrassed you know what I mean
it was just a little bit like yeah like
that man needed to be stopped and you
knew it because yeah this isn't the
first and this isn't the last comedians
sometimes take it upon ourselves to be
like like if I'm in a plane and someone
um is playing music like out loud
I'm like everyone's like and I'm like I
would love may I can I please like
can I please do it like like I like I
think we're very good at handling yes
really people that some people need to
be handled and I think we're in an
epidemic of there's just some the couple
people that just have not that need to
just get punched in the face
and then it's kind of like
look I I love movies I love going to the
movie theater I hate people
ruin the movie going experience and you
know that ArcLight attendant I'm that
Arc Light attendant now at every AMC I
go to where it's like excuse me ma'am
could you please turn that the fuck off
thank you I I just if there's one thing
that gets my temper going it's just the
disrespect of you're holding up the line
or one more thing yeah sorry just for
people yeah
you that night were probably getting
paid and we're not I'm not asking for
for like 15 if that so I think a lot of
times people oh yeah taxes but I mean
people are like oh the comic up here I
paid 20 so he's probably making five
thousand or he's a millionaire and
you're like not like nope you made the
mistake of coming into our house and um
fucking with people that have a lot to
lose but we live like we have nothing to
lose yeah and we've been disrespected by
so many people for so long and took it
that you kind of I I feel like I've seen
so many of my comedian friends where you
never know like one day something just
kind of benign someone's like you idiot
and they're like what the fuck and
you're like whoa yeah you've been on 10
roasts and you've like do the roast
battle like this is the thing like yeah
I think sometimes we just like hit our
limit like you were were you there the
night that I snapped and told everyone
to class it up no
[Music]
[Laughter]
but I fucking am I am all in for it well
I just out I
I hit my limb like I just
and it was like it just was I was so
like you guys you're introduced me to
your girlfriends and you're meeting your
wives and like just like I know I'm one
of the guys and you can trust me and I'm
over here in your conversations and like
oh she's a fucking Diamond it's like
it's all fine like these are like my
dudes like this is my wolf pack but I
started seeing it getting
sabotaging them like I saw a lot of
great comedy male comedians
start to get like success and start
being distracted by like girls which is
right right it's drugs it's great you
know just like like you haven't done new
jokes in four months dude why do you
have you you know what I mean stuff like
that like but but it's not my business
because then they're like well how come
I can't get to this and you're kind of
like well you know I don't know I don't
know everything is different for
everyone but
I think I was just like in that hallway
for so long and just seeing some like
not emotional
um
what is it when you're like it's not
stunted but a lack of growth emotional
right because I think as as Comics we
really can stay we can Peter Pan that
shit kind of as long as we want like we
have to force ourselves to grow yeah I I
I I agree it's so easy because again
there's no HR there's no
for a long time 100 yeah but we can stay
immature and playful on stage but like I
find the ones that really like long game
sustainable are the ones that are like
I'm a mature adult and I run my shit
tight and I'm not special and I don't
get to be king baby that where my like
Primal instant I want that like we don't
get to be fucking babies like Rich
babies is a dangerous fucking
combination right you know yeah and so
one night and this is obviously my
damage too I'm make I'm totally
accountable for I hadn't healed myself
around like my being like obsessed with
my dad's approval and obsessed with like
or being in relationships where guys
like they didn't cheat on me I I forced
them they they were not interested and
then I forced them to be with me and
then they kept doing the thing they said
they were gonna you know what I mean I
was just obsessed with like unavailable
emotion unavailable because it was like
familiar and chased them who cares who
cares so that um
the comic was telling a story about
sleeping with another female comic in
like a weird way and I think that kind
of it's like you do you don't do this to
female comments you know what I mean you
know female Comics like have had a past
of some kind of trauma so it's like I
think so he's telling the story and
everyone's laughing and I just like
got really like really intensely serious
right and just what like
[Laughter]
you know what you guys need to do
no no no no no hallway I was like you
guys need to class it up
and it was described back to me I
Believe by Mike young because I blacked
out he was like it just looked like a
helicopter that was coming down the
hallway and I was like and you need to
class it up and you stop bringing
girlfriends here because I know your
wife and you need to settle down it's
weird that you're 55 and have never been
along tour like every single person and
then Sebastian walked by it I went
you're fine
which by the way is so correct yeah they
never brought a girl to The Comedy Store
not once
yeah the funniest experience I ever had
on the road not to bring up a fight
story but Sebastian and I this is way
back in the day we're both single we met
some girls we hung out at the hotel I'm
like I'm gonna walk him to the car I'm
gonna walk into the to the elevator he
goes okay uh I'm just gonna hang back I
go okay so I go as I'm walking to the
elevator
two girls are in it there's a black guy
holding the door open with four black
guys behind him and he's trying to hit
on the girl and I hear him like come on
girl come on come on so I'm like oh shit
how do I do this so I kind of go into
the arm and I'm like hey you know we're
you know I get it we're we're all having
a good time but you know just walking
them back to the car please tell me you
did this hey all you guys like Sun Chips
it's on me yeah orange slices we're good
oh my God yeah
by the way groups of black guys respond
great to that what's up guys hello
Amigos
cheers my friends bottle up tonight
we're turning up so you guys trying to
tap that later he's going he's going
come on girl come on give me your number
give me a number she's like I'm not
giving my number and he's holding up his
necklace he's talking about his bling
and she's like I'm not giving you my
number he goes come on just give me your
number she goes I'm not giving you my
number you and then she drops the end
bomb Oh man
if I had four arms
so so now she's the famous uh actress
famous
podcast
so now he walks in the door's shut oh my
gosh shit so I kind of step in front and
we grab each other's shirts I played
hockey you know so you pull the Jersey
over the head and I'm just going for
broke so I'm sorry I played hockey so
you know just pull the Jersey over the
head pull the Jersey over the head that
was that was the fight move in hockey I
don't I didn't know that yeah so you and
I've dated an Armenian hockey guy
smelled great he told me about the best
smelling not if okay some yeah the ones
that have genocide ancestry maybe not
he's very like we don't I just
the best way to deal with an enemy is
deter them
or something yes he's like I'm not gonna
wash my shit because
then I'm gonna attract the kind of
people that give a shit there's like two
kinds of Armenian
tell me you were or three or four of
them the good one though the smell the
good smell well this one was from Little
Armenia down in uh L.A no but he's like
he's like comes from Armenia like I
think he's whatever first generation so
it's a lot of like we have one shirt and
we don't buy a new one got it because
you know this is very sad no he's so
funny yeah okay it's a funny shit ever
well it's good well anyways we get in a
fight right we're rocking around the
elevator stops and I'm stuck in mid-air
so anytime you hear Sarah Smiles by Hall
of notes I just like have like
flashbacks in CVS or Walgreens in the
elevator in an elevator cavities stuck
in midair and no fucking way hitting
this guy and he goes chill dog chill dog
chill I go are you done he goes chill
dog I go you're done he goes I'm done he
gets up the girl's crying he pulls his
shirt over his head and he's just
staring at me now and I'm in the
elevator like fuck he's gonna come at me
again we're not fucking moving this is
not going to be good and he's staring at
me and he looks really intently at me
and then he just goes uh were you on
BT's Comic View and I was like yeah yeah
I was he's like you do the Bruce Lee
thing I go yeah he goes I fucking love
that I go oh my fucking God I Go whoo
and he's like he's like man I really I
was like yeah that's why I'm here and I
met this fucking racist at the show I
didn't you know I didn't know and so now
he and I are hanging out right it's
fucking great all of a sudden it's
fucking cunt oh damn someone pull a
jersey over that fucking fucking
butterface let's Eiffel Tower her and so
then then the elevator goes back up and
the doors open his boys have been
sitting there waiting because they heard
the commotion everything as soon as it
opens Pop Pop I get hit shirt rip
bleeding here bleeding here the manager
the hotel goes I called the cops just
letting you guys know him and his boys
after they hit me he goes he goes guys
guys guys don't
remember Bruce Lee on BT's commentary
they go oh shit she's and then the guy
goes I call the cops they fucking take
off the girl in the elevator goes back
down I'm standing there the manager says
are you okay I go I'm okay this this
whole thing's been six minutes
blood blood shirt ripped I hear a door
open Sebastian in all Adidas stop it
comes out of the business center with a
frap and he looks at me goes what the
fuck happened are you a guy all right
the business center the business center
doing business doing business yes in
full Adidas gear like lotion he had it
all he had to he had to do a quick
little uh swing by Hugo boss.com
I think they got a promo code at the
show yeah he had to cash it in yeah that
it the only time not only but the most
embarrassing things I've ever done in
private yeah like at The Comedy Store
like I will look up and be like I hope
no one saw that and I turn around and
Sebastian was like
I'll be getting shit out of my car like
she'll be falling out like I'll drop
like a like a thing of Fig Newtons
it's so embarrassing I'll turn around
and smash the bag
[Applause]
I love that story so much because I love
the comics everyone wants to fight us
because we're Comics sometimes but the
only way to get out of a fight is for
them to wait you're a comic right you're
like yeah yeah and they're like oh
you're good and you're like hey like
leading with that gets me punched in the
face but after I can punch the face if
you learn after like I don't get a
second one like it's just like what the
fuck this is the shortest thing and then
we'll end because I I end things very
awkwardly and I'm very excited
um uh uh the last Late Night with Steve
Byrne amazon.com Amazon Prime yep it's
time to do it check it out I really
appreciate it yeah real quick just in
terms of having I think that a big part
of my um try to improve my brain now
that my my parents have both passed and
I'm just trying to like you know when
your parents there's just I had such an
entrenched emotion I wasn't able to like
grow a lot I I worry uh mature in
certain ways and learning how to course
correct it's like I've been very rigid I
mean like this is what works in life
with being a good friend being a good
girlfriend uh being a good um comedian
and then not going like because it used
to be like it takes an hour to write a
sorry it takes a year to write an hour
that's the deal and then you're like
sometimes it takes a year sometimes it
should be five years depending on the
thing I just I did really well with like
rigid rules and now I'm like oh no
flexible we gotta be flexible flexible
and I kind of learned this uh in terms
of using whatever like infamy or fame or
notoriety you have it to I'm big on like
Animal Welfare stuff and like how and
using it in any way that I can help like
usually behind the scenes because if you
post a publicly lose your leverage you
know so it's just like a sick addictive
fucking hobby
um but there was a as everyone not
everyone knows but there was a giraffe
in Malibu at that place Malibu Safari uh
during the Woolsey fires right so
there's like these horrible fires in
Malibu and there's a lot of animals that
don't get evacuated and I like I do like
volunteer equine evacuation and animal
evacuation during fires because it's
really hard to do most people can't get
animals on
trailers in a time of Crisis because
what you have to do is you have to do
rehearsals practices drills so you can't
just have a horse for five years and
then there's a fire and there's chaos
and they're not going to get on the
trailer you have to like twice a year
I'm sure they're reacting to the smells
and sights of everything that and the
fear of the person trying to get them on
so they can get on a trailer when it's
calm but when it's like there's
ambulances and Sirens are like we gotta
go so we do drills where you create
stress you bang on pants and you make
and you shake the trailer and then work
on getting the horse on so that they can
wow so they can do it in time of Crisis
also because anyone can do it in a time
of calm easy right but it's I need to
get three horses on I have 10 minutes
like you know whatever so there's this
giraffe in Malibu and I am not as I've
never attempted suicide I've never
thought about suicide it sounds like a
lot of like
work right
um or just like not the solution for
whatever right sure it's just like it
just it seems you know not for me and I
it like kills me that people whoa feel
that way because I'm like it's I can
usually relate to most people's like
pain I'm like oh wait I had like that I
just like I'll you know I guess it might
just be a chemical thing that maybe
we'll never understand who knows I don't
know
but I did through the Woolsey fires like
the only way to it was everything was on
fire phone lines were down like it was
like fucking Mars up there in Malibu and
I had to get to this draft and I did
drive over like Fallen electrical lines
like oh over it you know I mean I just
was like I was like like that let's go
like it was just but there were three
checkpoints right so there was a police
checkpoint uh because you couldn't get
past the first place checkpoint in order
to get past the first one you had to be
uh LAPD lafd uh in order to get past the
second one you had to be higher level
you know and then the last one was like
you know eight fire whatever and like
one no it was actually one and there
were eight on the second one right so
the first one I'm like oh fuck everyone
I see ahead of me is driving up the
checkpoint making you turn driving up
right they lived there sure they can't
go to their own homes and so I pull up
and I'm like
like hey guys I'm just like visiting a
friend
whatever and like are you any comings
I'm like yes yes I am and I'm just gonna
pick her up and then I'm like I'll be so
quick I'll be so quick I can literally
an hour later your fucking friend is a
giraffe put the fucking head out the
fucking window like what the fuck is
that
like guys it's a Toys R Us I do it
pay partnership with Toys R Us quick
just put your head down I'm a fucking
giraffe the way men do it with girls
so then I'm like and they're like let me
buy because I'm that I'm convincing I
really pull out my acting chops just for
cops uh not TV shows and then second one
it's like there's like eight and you're
like this isn't good this is like like
uniforms there's smoke I mean we're in
Smoke right there's smoke on either side
of us it's like no one's getting but no
one should have gone past that sure then
I go up and I'm like hey guys I actually
I I know this sounds crazy but they
already are kind of are like she got
past the first one so they you know then
you get this thing where they're like
she's pre-approved why why you know some
of the second one it's like a mile down
I'm like hey guys I'm so sorry this is
so embarrassing but I uh my name is when
it comes I do your Chris like I've done
your Christmas party a couple times like
no fucking way like what's up dude and I
was like Hey I was like I know I'm not
supposed to be here like I know this is
super dangerous like I just have to get
one thing I just work in Animal Welfare
this would make like I just have to drop
one thing off yeah I just have a
generator for somebody and like I swear
I'll turn around I can even leave my car
here if you want yeah or like take my
phone whatever you need to know that I'm
not you know yeah and then I like
they're like you have 10 minutes or
something or something you know what I
mean and I'm like
and then bile another checkpoint fucking
fucking God damn it and they're all
caught talking and by the time I get to
him I know he's like hey Whitney wow
yeah what's up yeah and I was like
do you want to see a giraffe
and he went fuck yeah
let's go
like you just have to like pivot yeah
sometimes you gotta just get to it you
gotta accomplish whatever it is the
mission is especially that's that's
amazing that you do that a it's
something I would I would have never
thought of when I see wildfires Etc uh
in California but now that I see that it
is something that it's like in the
Rolodex now I think it's because of
somebody like you educating so I mean
it's like you know what I mean like a
lot of people in L.A have horses and
they don't know shit about horror like
they have a lot of animals they don't
know anything about it's like fine it's
just rich people that are like I want to
be a horse person or like I want to have
horses in my Instagrams or something and
it's like the horses die of colic
because we're out in a desert and there
you have to use this thing called like
they just don't they have horses and no
trailers I mean it's like I think it's
that's illegal but no one cares about
animals their property their cars you
know so it's like a bunch of people have
horses but they don't have trailers to
move them when the horse is sick or the
horse needs to get out of a fire sure
and then they're getting out their you
know vintage cars and other animals like
kind of you know I mean which is the
best thing you can do is just open their
Gates and horses know what to do right
so you just go to their shoes and you
write the phone number and the location
of the horse yeah let the horse go yeah
because they'll get away from fires on
their own yeah and then someone will you
know find them bring them back like we
deal with that they'll be safe but if
they're in a barn right they will die
obviously which is what happened in Ojai
like a bunch of horses were trapped in
because that was the because it was a
a door with the with bars or they'll try
to get out and I mean the pictures of my
phone make me want to kill yourself and
they rip their chest open and died lead
to death or infection or it's like
they're so injured break their legs
because horses break their legs they
can't they don't live you know what I
mean so it's like it's just more like
like I love I just I love to do it like
I feel you know because I uh I don't
have kids so I'm like you guys have kids
you can't do this like I'll do it and
then when I
can't do it anymore someone else
this is this is what's called classing
it up
this is classing it up I love it
I end these very awkwardly
I'm obsessed with you
uh I said to Pat I was like okay I don't
want to keep him just do an hour and a
half hour and a half don't let me go
over yeah
what do we do four hours what well shut
up first she put you on ice for 40
minutes okay that okay okay okay three
and then we did three okay wow okay it's
been four hours three what if you've
been here for four oh this doesn't even
seem like this feels like two hours yeah
because we like each other yeah this is
one of the best episodes we've taped oh
wow I I agree yeah that's very kind God
never says that this is one of like four
where I'm like gut laughing the whole
time oh wow well that's and who's
expense
mostly yours his favorite episode are
when 20-year friends of mine come in
yeah and make fun of me in ways that no
one else can he loves it when people
that like have are not scared of me at
all just comment and like remember when
you like lied about that thing or
whatever
well I I you this is the only podcast
where the host doesn't need a microphone
so it's always a pleasure to be here oh
Whitney that was just a fun you know I
truly genuinely no I know Perfection and
love for you yeah over the course of the
years of doing this there's like I was
saying during that that pandemic thing
where there's people where you just pick
it right back up again and I always I'm
glad family so thank you so much
um I
assuming I am operating under
the right definition of love I do love
you
what my definition of I do love you
I would say that to you cool see you in
six years okay
I mean like truly don't ride elephants
[Music]
[Applause]